today
i'll call this meeting of the house
judiciary committee to order
and we'll begin our meeting by pledging
allegiance to the flag and
representative dilorenzo could you lead
us in that pledge
to the flag
of the united states of america
mr clark
representative gordon here
walker is here representative sylvia
representative alexander
um
you can put one in your package
representative
representative green
representative kelly
representative andrus
representative trottier
representative marjorie smith
representative chase representative
kenny
representative langley
representative
okay our first item of business this
morning is a hearing on house bill
1013 relative to meetings of the new
hampshire rare disease advisory council
and
i'll call upon one of the sponsors
representative woods to introduce the
bill and provide testimony today
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
committee for hearing this bill
this is a really a very straightforward
build relative to the meetings of this
very special
advisory council
it was formulated by house bill 237 in
2019 uh so we're just getting underway
the difficulty is
with this committee is
a lot of the participants that are on
the committee
have
rare diseases themselves
and because they're immunosuppressed uh
cannot participate in in
public
events
uh under the coveted uh problems that
we're having at the moment
we have not been able to do
administrative tasks
like passing
our minutes we review our minutes each
month
and make sure there's any corrections
but we can't vote on them because we
can't we'd have to have an in-person
quorum so our ask is that we can
officially meet
virtually and conduct our business
virtually
the
prime sponsor is representative marsh
who is chair of the
advisory council i'm vice chair of the
council
he
has to introduce a bill in another
committee and ask me to substitute for
him
his request was i just read his very
short
presentation
uh just uh for the record my
representative william marsh carol eight
representing towns uh seven towns in
southern carroll county
here today to introduce 1013 relative to
the meetings of the new hampshire rare
advisory council
i filed this bill at the request of the
rare disease advisory council and in my
capacity as its chair
i have to introduce another bill at this
moment my vice chair and co-sponsor
representative gary woods is here to
introduce the bill
briefly the rationale for this bill is
listed in the bill itself
over half of the membership of the rare
disease advisory council is
immunocompromised
either from their disease or the
treatment for their disease
since the lift the lifting of the state
emergency we have done our business
and continue to meet in a hybrid fashion
but we've been unable to obtain a full
quorum in person while i don't recall a
single controversial vote ever being
taken in the history of the rare disease
advisory council
we are not able to administer a function
such as approving the minutes
allowing this particular council the
ability to meet remotely would enable us
to continue the work we have been
charged to do
i thank you and i will come to the
committee to answer questions as soon as
i finish in legislative administration
thank you mr chair
thank you are there questions for
representative wood
representative wolper
uh thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh do you have any
idea what you would prefer to see
as a requirement in the right to know
i i really wouldn't know the wording for
that exactly
yes
so
i have no idea the size of the advisory
board
but a quorum is
expected to be 51 of the membership
correct
just what's your reaction to say he said
something like
five
members or
what could you know physically president
could constitute
or
would you rather see us say something
like uh
of the the size of the board
anything would be an improvement put it
that way
it's difficult to to say that would be
adequate
yes that would be
to our advantage to have a lower number
as a quorum or to conduct business
what that number would be
any as i say anything would be an
advantage
thank you i'll tell you we struggle with
that all summer we're going to struggle
with it for the rest of this year
any other questions yes representative
sylvia
yeah it was uh out of um house bill um
two through uh 237 in uh the 2000 or
2019 session
well with covet it's certainly much more
uh much wider spread and uh
and the consequences of of covet is uh
much more sequential
consequential uh than the regular flu
but yes uh
even in the regular sessions there were
people who
did not uh come and and meet uh
on a regular basis with us for this same
reason
sorry
i thought i got it um
so
the the members of this board um
do they not participate
in regular life go to doctor's offices
go to
uh shopping um
are they are they
so
incapacitated uh that they can't go out
in public
many of them are yes
they virtually do have during covid uh
they've been homebound they have home
delivery for groceries
uh and such uh they do telemedicine as
much as as at all possible uh for
follow-up care obviously some of them
get iv medications
and have to come to the medical centers
so it
they do interact but many of them
that are really very seriously
immunosuppressed uh
really
carry on a very restrictive
existence eve even outside the pandemic
thank you
representative horgan
thank you very much mr chair thank you
much representative woods um
i mean
would you be uh
i mean would you be amenable
although i don't know whether this could
fly through the full house even the
committee to uh using this as a vehicle
for
restoring the remote meetings as was
done with the state of mercy's effect
and i think pretty successfully um
or do you feel like we should just
stick with this uh committee with it
which has like apparently unique
considerations
my sense is that the council would not
like to to
proffer themselves as as representing a
more general consideration but we have
very specific needs under these
circumstances
um and they're very well delineated and
i think pretty well understood by almost
everybody that aiming of suppression is
a rather significant player in this
pandemic and we'd like to leave it as is
right thanks
are there any other questions for
representative woods
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
the next book
we do have the prime sponsor of the bill
here i don't know if he would also like
to testify we did hear some of his
written testimony and
do you have a call upon representative
marsh to see if he has anything in
addition to add uh thank you mr chairman
i'm not entirely aware of what you
already heard uh because i wasn't here
in the room i was introducing another
bill upstairs and i apologize for that i
can only be in one place at a time
the the this bill was submitted at the
request of the rare disease advisory
council
simply because the rare disease advisory
council has been unable to make a quorum
since the end of the state of emergency
because over half of our members are
immunocompromised
we've done our best to carry on the
business of the the council in a hybrid
fashion but we can't approve our minutes
and it would be very nice if we had a
mechanism of
doing the things that we need to get
done
uh
did you read the letter
i don't need to be any longer than that
because he read my testimony to you
thank you
other questions for representative marsh
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you
representative marsh for taking my
question
when was this
legislation
proposed or asked for by the board
it was not officially asked for by the
board because we don't have a quorum to
hold a vote on anything but all the
members discussed it with me offline and
ask that we
submit it
so
um
i think that sounds like it
never mind
i'm all set
any other questions for representative
marsh
i get to do
my one question is obviously the
requirements that are in place now
were in place prior to covid
in terms of
the meeting requirements quorum
requirements
and
was getting a
quorum
problematic before covid
uh no having aquarium quorum is never a
problematic before cor before coveted
actually we've come pretty close we've
come within one
uh attendee of having a physical quorum
present where the meeting was held but
we haven't actually made that quorum
since the state of emergency started
any other questions representative marsh
you for your testimony
next we call upon
dr sai
sharala
shirawa
yes
good morning chair and good morning
committee members for your record my
name is dr sai sharala spelled
c-h-e-r-a-l-a
first name is sai
um i'm the bureau chief for the
population health and community services
in the division of public health we are
here representing the department in
support of this bill
and administratively we support the
rare disease advisory council and has
the representative martian
representative which are presented one
other issue with this group is the
immuno compromise group of participants
and we want to be very flexible to
support their participation and work in
which we have seen the work happening
during the whole emergency and we feel
that that's an option to provide that
services for that group so we are in
support for that uh for this bill
do you have any questions or i'm happy
to answer any questions you have
any questions for the doctor
representative sylvia
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um
i i haven't looked up the uh the depth
of this board could you tell us uh how
many members and uh how they are
appointed
uh these are uh these are appointed to
the it was a legislative council so that
was selected through the uh through the
the bill
and we have roughly around uh
at this point of time 13 members
representing different rare disease
groups as well as
new hampshire medical society
as well as the department as well as the
legislative members
thank you and follow up yes you may
uh prior to this
the formation of this council
how did dhhs look at
rare diseases and what was the process
we never had a we never had a forum to
look at the rare disease this was our
beginning of the process
and that's where we have put some of our
rare disease advisory council has our
starting point to look at understanding
what's the
prevalence of rare disease in new
hampshire as well as thinking about how
we educate our
general public as well as our medical
providers and also working with our
health insurance providers on how we
treat these conditions
thank you
any other questions for the doctor
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much
next person is laurie
ortolano
good morning
my name is lori ordolano i live in
nashua i'm vice president of right to
know new hampshire and we do not support
hb 1013 relative to changing the format
of meetings of the new hampshire rare
disease advisory council
while we are sympathetic to board
members that are autoimmune compromised
a physical location must be provided for
all public meetings
this new paragraph amendment to rsa
126-a colon 79 allows no physical
location to be available
additionally if only electronic means
are provided this may limit attendance
of some members of the public in remote
areas that do not have access to
technology
in nashua the physical location is a
critical component of our public
meetings
very often before the start of a meeting
and after adjournment members of the
public engage their ward representatives
in dialogue on the business of the board
not all members of the public are
comfortable speaking and participating
on the record some choose a more
personal face-to-face approach to
discuss city matters
these social connections are an
important part of doing business and a
physical location provides a means for
this to happen
additionally conducting business and
negotiating which often happens with new
legislation consists of verbal and
non-verbal cueing the body language of
our board members signals messaging on
voting positions this type of
communication can only be captured when
meetings maintain a physical location
remote access through video means does
not always capture the room and
telephonic remote access completely
eliminates all interpersonal connections
and non-verbal communication
public business will be practiced like
oz the man behind the curtain
seeing and hearing the entire elected
body is an important part of public
meetings for these reasons right to know
new hampshire supports public meetings
to include one a physical location must
be provided
two the quorum of the board present in
the physical location must be defined by
the committee and i'll pause here to say
that ordinarily we have supported the
physical quorum to be uh 50 plus one
half the body
you know i'm sympathetic to what this
committee is saying
and i believe the gentleman who spoke
mentioned that about half the people
could attend but not quite get to the
quorum
i i would like to think that everyone
who can physically be in attendance
would be in attendance
board members participating remotely
must give a reason why remote
participation is required any member
participating in such fashion shall
identify the location from which the
person is participating and the persons
present in the location from which the
meeting is participating virtual access
either telephonic or video must be
provided in the meeting notice required
to be posted under rsa 91a colon 2.
each member participating electronically
or otherwise shall be able to
simultaneously hear each other speak
to each other during the meeting and
shall be audible or otherwise
discernible to the public in attendance
the public must have a means to notify
the committee if access if they cannot
access the meeting and the meeting must
be adjourned
if the public is unable to access the
meeting
so in listening to the prior testimony i
am
uh curious that before
the pandemic hit in 2019 that they were
able to
have these meetings and it seems to me
that the situation of having a quorum or
getting together is a result of the
pandemic and i i personally don't
support that a pandemic environment is
going to be here forever
um so i
um you know i hate to see legislation
enacted that
allows this type of remote meeting
forever when it might not be necessary
there are a number i think there are
four or five bills like this for remote
meetings and the message from right to
know new hampshire is going to be very
consistent on all of them to oppose
meetings not having a physical location
thank you
any questions for
octalano
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um having experienced
the the zoom meeting world last year um
i did not find the technology
actually capable of doing simultaneous
um
speaking and hearing it was there's
always a delay it's almost
impossible to
have a real-time kind of conversation
like we have here is is that a concern
that you have yes definitely and down in
nashua where technology is pretty good
those problems exist
particularly telephonic you have a lag
time
that's significant and um
you know the video has been problematic
even a week ago we had major video
problems
in our meeting and uh you you know
you're just delayed and so it's not a
surefire thing and i'm concerned that
people from all different areas or more
remote areas of the state would have
issues
thank you
any other questions yes representative
simpson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um
when you were speaking about nonverbal
cues and meetings and social
interactions that happened before and
after meetings i'm
i'm wondering if you can tell me is that
in the right to know statutes that those
things are protected in the same way
that the verbal speaking is no
thank you
and i have another question as well you
may follow up
thank you um this is actually a
different question um and your you said
your group is opposed to all bills about
rem remote meetings
but i wonder if you talked at all about
um the difference between a commission
like this that has particular members
and meets on particular issues to solve
particular problems versus
a meeting like the nashua town city
council that would be um
i assume you have a city council sorry
if that's not right
that would be open to um board of
aldermen right
would be open to uh all members of the
public as opposed to a specific 13
members who absolutely needed to discuss
business that of course is open to the
public but in a different way than maybe
a board of aldermen no we consider that
all the same way because if it meets
the requirements of 91a to be a public
meeting and a buy to the law then
blanket it falls under that doesn't
matter if it's advisory or an authority
set up or an agency or a public elected
body whether they're appointed or
elected if they have to comply with 91a
we
that's how we look at this
okay thank you yeah
representative horgan
um thank you very much mr chair thank
you mr ortolano um
when
uh
i've um i've seen in your testimony
today which and um others they talk
about the uh
ability to
speak informally with uh
members of the public body before and
after but isn't
does that doesn't conflict potentially
with 91a which is designed to minimize
the amount of uh
sort of uh
off record uh
informal discussion try to get things
hashed out as much as possible
in public
no not at all
um because 91a
controls communications between the
boards such that quorums of the board
can't do business outside of meetings
but individual members of the public
that come in to speak to an individual
board member whether it's their ward rep
or not
even if they email them those emails are
not subject to public disclosure
any individual member of the public
emailing a ward rep you cannot put in a
right to know and get those
communications those are communications
that are considered private and not
disclosable
so it's only when it goes to the full
body that it becomes disclosed
so
that in communication beforehand is very
valuable i came in here and asked not
relative to this but several questions
before the meeting started to a couple
of the members that were in here
super helpful i could get some
information
a little more about the legislative body
and
i did exactly what i would do in a
public meeting down in nashua
those physical locations apply
provide that communication and i can
tell you in nashua at the beginning and
end of meetings there's a lot of public
circulation to individual members of the
board to say something or share
something many times it may not be an
item on the agenda it might be something
coming up
so
no
unless they're trying to hurt a whole
group of the board together and say i
want to influence your vote on something
that's on the agenda today that would be
a problem and the board would know to
shut that down i've actually never
witnessed that so individual
communication does not violate the
spirit of 91a
all right thank you
representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question mr orlano you know i am
i am a stroke survivor and i have some
physical limitations and i know how hard
it is to get around
this group
the rare disease
group um it sounds like
a lot of the folks that are on that
council
have mobility issues and mobility
problems which are
exasperated by the pandemic so i think
that
these folks should be able to get a
reasonable accommodation to
attend and view
by video or you or um
zoom
those are my comments thank you
i don't necessarily disagree with you
because what we wrote here was that we
just believe that a physical location
should be provided
okay and um some level of a remote we
support the legislation i can't remember
the bill number that allows virtual
meetings for the public to participate
in we still want the elected body to
have
a physical location and if members of
that elected body choose to use
zoom or telephonic they have to identify
why they're doing that
um
so we're very we love the broadened
scope of public participation in
meetings that has come through
telecommunications that's been pretty
terrific um
so i'm sympathetic when i wrote this up
i really had no details on this i wasn't
able to hear what the size of this
committee is and we i'd had no
information on what the struggle was or
how close the quorum was it sounds like
they're pretty close to getting a quorum
and and maybe there should be
some board members added that can be
that don't are not health compromised
that can make that quorum up sometimes
bodies are too big
um
to get the quorum you need because
there's 20 or 30 people on them and at a
time like this
you're struggling to get a quorum
because you've made a legislative body
that's too big to get it
you got to revisit that and decide
whether your commission or your
appointed advisory group needs to be
that large
thank you thank you
other questions
yes representative
langley thank you
thank you mr chair and good morning
thank you for taking my question
i you just alluded to some flexibility
in terms of how you would take a look at
the meeting structure
i was wondering would you consider some
type of a hybrid model that would
incorporate
the cheer perhaps of the committee
making a decision those who were immune
compromised or at high risk for coming
into a physical
place could attend via video or whatever
the form was that was developed and the
remaining members would attend a
physical location
would that be something that you would
even consider i can't really speak to
that because i'd have to bring it to the
group and address that with the group i
don't want to address it as an
individual because i am representing
right to know new hampshire any other
questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify
on house bill 1013
seeing no one will close the hearing on
house bill 1013
we'll move on to our next item of
business which is a hearing on house
bill
1023 relative to regulation of athletic
agents
i have one card right now and that is
for representative josh ocala
welcome
thank you mr chair thank you members of
the committee
um
this bill is about athlete agents
and
currently
there is no
wh well there is uh
training and education requirements
for many of like if you wanted to
represent an nfl athlete or age
um in uh
required by the nfl
there's no training or
education requirements for the license
in new hampshire
new hampshire just takes your money
and
you sign a piece of paper and thank you
very much
you you're now an athlete agent
and so
i looked uh
in the last session to repeal that since
that is
um
not a good use of
of our time
but there was some value in the fact
brought to my attention
by uh
unh the people that will be speaking
next i'm sure
um
that
an athlete agent has the potential to
harm
a college through inter indirect means
which they wouldn't
um which the college would have no
recourse
to uh
to that athlete agent without this the
uh the statute
which gives them a cause of action
because
the
there are certain
uh rules by the ncaa
and other organizations that
that schools contract with that
do things like punish the school if the
student does something to become
make them eligible
and uh
an athlete agent
depending what they talk about depending
what the athlete agent gives the student
can put the school in breach of that
contract
and so
this schools wanted to be able to
have a recourse
against the athlete agent when the
athlete agent
is the cause of those
damages
so
what i'm proposing in this bill
is that we remove the requirement
of
of signing up for a registration and
renewal of registration and just
allow
that schools to
to uh
still
maintain that right to
recuperate the damages
so this this will
continue to keep the
the um
the damages
being able to be sued
also it strengthens the student athletes
right
to sue
if
the
athlete agent does something
without warning them ahead of time that
this is going to affect their
eligibility and it harms the athlete
they would also be able to sue
in this example or in this in this bill
but we wouldn't so all of the
kind of the point of this is
if someone is harmed that they should be
able to
to sue
and but there's no need to assume that
the person is going to be dangerous or
anything that the government needs to
have the registration for beforehand
and so
that's why i'm removing i want seeking
to remove the registration
aspect
of
this the uh rsa
332 j
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you
questions for representative ocala
yes
yes representative walper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question i am some confused
here
okay because it sounded to me as if you
said
that
the school could be punished
for actions of which it had no knowledge
yep or participation yep
that doesn't make any sense to me
well
uh the ncaa
ncaa i'm not sure uh intends to make
sense so that is
uh not
that is beyond my purview but the
the school essentially
has a contract with ncaa that says you
know these students
that that you say are eligible at the
time of you know the beginning of the
school year or whatever
they're not going to take any actions to
make themselves ineligible if you
if they
do then you're going to be punished both
this the student can be punished and the
school can be punished that they are
a part of and
um
the interactions between the athlete
agent and the
the
student athlete
can have the effect of making them
ineligible and so the school
there is a requirement in this to um
or in the current statute to let to let
uh the school know within a certain
amount of time and if
there's damages
that they would
um be on the hook for them currently
that's how it is written
obviously i'm
much less of an expert than the people
that are from unh and know and know
about the intricacies of these contracts
and be able to
maybe
give you more information about how
they're indirectly being punished
or they're they're
they're being punished for no actions
that they've directly taken
that
is the main reason why they did not want
this
whole statute to be repealed they just
want they um
were quite adamant on that so
other questions
rep representative simpson
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question representative
um
do i'm not very familiar with this as
well but i'm wondering is there a kind
of like an education or certification
process for um agents of athletes
no
so
i guess that's
there's no requirement or education
require education requirement or
anything for the
for getting a license in new hampshire
however there are
programs for
if you want to be an nfl athlete agent
then yes there is a very expensive and
and time-consuming
process to become an athlete agent for
the nfl or any major team
sports however there is
now with opportunity of
high school and college students to be
able to
under the new ncaa rules make money
there can be
like i could go to an athlete and say
hey
bob's pizza shop wants to give you 50 or
free pizza once a week if you go on
their you know uh flyer or something
like that and they can make those money
deals now without being ineligible and
so
the there's no real education
requirement for something like that
but
um if you wanted to be at a high level
like
in a um
mba or something like that there's going
to be requirements to be an athlete
agent for those people yes thank you for
the question
other questions
i guess the question that i have is it
if i heard your testimony correctly
you want to do away with the requirement
current requirement that
athletic agents be registered right for
the state
and
but
the other part your other intent is to
make them
uh accountable right for harm
that they make because yes retain the
accountability right now they're
accountable
and in kind of a
the schools can
can recoup damages and the state can
can impose fines
but
going forward i'm saying that
the school could
or
get damages or the athlete agent could
get damages the state doesn't really
need to be involved
with that yeah
well i guess it gets to my question
right and that is
who is an athletic agent
so if they're not in some manner
identified
so because
joe
schmoe who
just
runs the pizza parlor and gives the kid
fifty dollars
does he become an athletic agent yes
well is that defined someplace in the
statute well it's defined yes
happy to read the
definition section
the the definition section is on line
one through three of the bill
um so all
if you just look it's crossing out the
the um
uh or wait no any where is it
yes any person in the name of any person
who is compensated because the athlete
agent signed an agency contract
so if they sign a contract with that
person to
be paid royalties essentially or a fee
part of that contract to benefit from
the contract let's say with the
you know pizza parlor if you get a cut
of that then you would be the athlete
agent
okay and i don't want to
sound anal but it sounds like you have
to sign a contract
which means which implies there needs to
be a
written contract
so
if i'm
joe pizza man and i give somebody i tell
the kid i'm going to give you 50 bucks
if you'll put your face on my flyer
would that not would that fall within
that definition
are you are you
saying that the pizza place would be
they the the
because they signed the paper is that
what you're saying
well i i thought when i asked a question
earlier and he said if joe pizza right
gives a kid fifty dollars right to have
his face on the flyer
does that make him
an athlete athlete agent
and i thought you said yes to the
earlier question so i'm trying so
are you are you talking about the pizza
person or the pre like uh someone that's
facilitating the contract
no i was talking about the pizza person
okay
no because
under this definition they would need to
be compensated so the pizza person would
not be paying themselves
as part of the contract i mean unless
they wanted to that's
don't
they
i don't i don't think joe pizza is gonna
say okay i'm gonna get ten dollars you
get fifty dollars for you being on the
on the flyer right
well
i'm presuming that miss pizza man
is putting the kid's face on the flyer
because he's
indicates he's going to get more
business right and
in that manner be compensated some type
of remuneration
why don't i ask a different question and
that is
is there a need to do away with the
registration does the registration cause
any harm in any manner
i mean
harm
in the fact that it creates a barrier to
entry
and that there's a fee
that
that would also
let's say if you want to go around
paying fifty dollars for
for you know this high school player to
be on your
on your uh pizza place
or you or you want to be an athlete
agent for this high school that the kids
are only going to get fifty dollars then
even a 50
and you're gonna get some percentage of
that maybe ten dollars
even a fifty dollar fee
is
like all of your profits right so or a
significant portion of the profits for
for an entire school so it would create
a barrier to entry to
what's going to be a much more
um
with the new rules a much
more
lower end contract pizza shop
down the street or the auto body shop or
whatever
those those opportunities
may be to
to younger or
high school students or
or what have you and they may now be
paid a significant amount of money so
the athlete agent trying to get them
that money
would also not be making that much money
doing that so there is
that barrier to entry and obviously
anytime
i i think that it's
any time that we can remove those
barriers to entry into the workplace is
good if if they're not necessary
thank you for the question
other questions
yes representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
for your calendar take my question i'm
getting a little bit twisted in my mind
here um and the way that i envision what
this law says or this lsr says is that
um
the athlete
can have an agent
the agent would be the person getting
the residuals for the athlete
correct
they
obviously the age the athlete could go
directly to the pizza shop for example
and get their fifty dollars directly
the the value add from the athlete agent
is trying to go track down those pizza
places that want
okay the person that just said hey go
talk to the guy that went up that down
at the pizza shop right um
follow it may i follow up okay so um
can an athlete under this bill have more
than one agent
absolutely
you might have you know a t
tv agent you might have you know an an
agent that is trying to
um
get you radio spots maybe they have more
connections in that field you could be
you know
trying to get you sponsorships there
could be
but
there just like any other thing any
other thing there can be specialized
fields where you know you really want to
go to this guy for your pizza shop ones
but the auto dealers he doesn't have any
connections with so you want to go to
talk to someone else right thank you
absolutely
any other questions for representative
ocala
seeing none thanks thanks absolutely
thank you
i have a card which says tom cronin and
sean green
representing unh
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is tom cronin i'm the
director of government relations for the
university system i'm here with my
colleague sean green who is the
associate athletic director for
compliance at the university of new
hampshire uh thank you for the
opportunity to speak for a few minutes
today on house bill 1023
but maybe just to clarify at the start
so current state statute rsa 332 colon j
is a set of regulations that governs the
activity of athlete agents those are the
folks who have the authority to act as
intermediaries essentially between an
athlete a student athlete and a business
seeking to do business with that athlete
right so somebody who can enter into
contracts on behalf of etc
up until relatively recently it's been a
pretty dormant section of state statute
has really sort of changed uh the game
no pun intended for uh college athletes
right they now have significantly more
opportunities to develop revenue off of
their abilities off of their images like
this etc
at unh and across the university system
we are
incredibly supportive of this
opportunity for our athletes uh sean and
his team have worked diligently to put
policies in place that provide a really
a broad latitude of opportunity for
athletes to take advantage of this
in addition to changes to nil
that has sort of almost broken a dam if
you will
on behalf of the ncaa
sorry nil's name image and likeness it's
sort of a vernacular around that issue
broken a dam for the uh ncaa in terms of
really just looking at how they govern
all of athletics across the country in
every division uh we expect i think next
week the ncaa is looking at a relatively
wholesale rewrite of their constitution
that is going to result in uh reviews of
policies across the board in college
athletics so with all that said i think
our biggest ask of the committee on this
bill is perhaps just a little bit of
caution before moving forward on this
section knowing there is still so much
change
if i could just maybe speak to a couple
points first
really a thanks to the sponsor uh as you
mentioned he's been working on this bill
for a couple of years and has been
incredibly communicative with us um and
an opportunity to kind of develop what
you have before you today
we are not necessarily opposed to i
think the sponsor's main purpose which
is to
remove a barrier of entry to somebody
who might want to be an athlete agent um
to the degree the state needs to
regulate this you know there probably is
some benefit if you read 332 j
particularly the first few sections it
does talk a bit about an application
process
requires agents to talk about their
education the athlete
is working with an agent that this
person is reputable there's something to
be said for that for sure um
in its place the way the representative
has drafted 1023 does provide we think
significant legal recourse both for
institutions and for athletes who might
be harmed there's no doubt about that so
we certainly appreciate it he did
mention um a new section of statute that
actually does create a cause of action
for students as well that did not exist
before we certainly would be supportive
of that
um with that said we'd maybe urge a
particular caution on two repeal
sections at the bottom of the bill
332 j12
that requires agents to maintain
contract records for five years
um
you know if if the committee moves
forward with repealing the other
sections of statute
or athletes really would have no
simple way of doing due diligence on
somebody seeking to represent them um
requiring an agent to as the current law
stands maintain contracts make those
contracts uh publicly accessible does at
least give a student who might want to
engage in an agent an opportunity to do
some due diligence
not sure that would really be a full
substitute for the existing regulation
requirement but we do think it would be
an important piece to try and leave in
there and second is j15 again the
representative mentioned right now in
law there is a significant civil penalty
that the secretary of state can enforce
currently this section is enforced by
the secretary of state's office i think
it's 25 000 for violation uh again we
appreciate that uh institutions and
athletes would have the opportunity to
pursue a case in the court system uh
obviously a significant monetary fine is
another you know deterrent towards a bad
actor
you know i think maybe in summary i
would just say
while there's a lot of new opportunity
there's still a lot of confusion as i
think some of the questions have uh sort
of brought about and at least right now
there is a very very thin line
between an athlete pursuing nil
opportunities so the opportunity to put
a face on a flyer for the pizza shop and
return for 50
and a a small misstep that can result in
that athlete losing their eligibility in
the ncaa entirely that is essentially
any conversation somebody that that
athlete trusts to resent represent them
has with
anything to do with a professional
career in athletics inadvertently or
purposefully
right now i think the monetary benefit
for agents as again was discussed is
pretty low on some of our nil deals and
sean can speak a little bit more to that
if there's questions about them the real
opportunity for agents is that next step
it's bringing an athlete into the
professional market that is where an
agent can make money there is a
incredible incentive for agents to have
that in the back of their mind where any
misstep before an athlete is allowed to
do that can severely jeopardize that
athlete's future could jeopardize the
prospect of our athletic teams and any
other athletic teams in the ncaa so with
all that said i think our our urging
really is just a little bit more caution
a little bit more time to see how the
ncaa moves on these um and then some
degree of
perhaps looking at this and other
statutes in the future um i miss
anything that you'd add to that or
if not lesser specific questions yeah
we're happy to take questions
representative silvia
thank you mr sharon thank you for taking
my question
i see here that this
legislation was put in place in 2006
it looks to be untouched since do you
know
what inspired this legislation in the
first place
it's free my time
it's pretty my time as well thank you
for the question uh
i i do not know the answer to that
question
okay thank you
other questions
representative lorenzo did you have a
question thank you mr chair and i have a
question um
during um
your testimony
um
you had said that we should proceed with
caution about
you know
writing any legislation or um
voting on any legislation in in relation
to this and is that because of the ncaa
changing their rules
so this i think is maybe the third time
in the last few years there's been a
piece of legislation related to uh ncaa
regulations particularly around nil
right certainly following the california
case a few years ago and as the ncaa has
continued to try and figure out the
right path forward and i think we would
agree with anybody who is frustrated
with how long that is taking and how
challenging it is for folks like shawn
and compliance and our athletes trying
to understand the rules they
nevertheless are the rules that we need
to play by and any changes we make at a
local level that put us in conflict with
ultimately where those bodies come down
could be a challenge for our athletes in
the future so it is until that
environment settles a little bit that is
that is sort of our request and if i
could mr chair a question a question i
think you asked at the end of the
previous speaker's testimony to our
knowledge there
isn't a problem right now we agree that
perhaps a 50 fee uh is maybe burdensome
for some but we have we are not hearing
from students who wish to have agents
who can't as a result of the state's
current uh regime around this um
and so i think again
without a clear and present issue that
we're trying to solve
i think we would caution that doing
anything moving in one direction that
then we need to come back and suggest to
this or another committee down the line
uh needs changes
if i could jump in to answer to
contribute to that as well
sorry sorry
um i would say the short answer to your
question is probably yes the ncaa
convention actually convenes today um
and as uh thomas pointed out they'll be
rewriting the entire constitution the
draft has already been published they're
not rewriting it they're actually voting
to approve it and then once that
constitution is approved
they will begin rewriting
entire sections of the ncaa rule book
that we all have to follow um and so as
a result of that there will be a lot of
change coming in the next few months
yeah excuse me i thought do you have a
time frame
they have stated that these rules would
be in place by august 1st of 2022.
thank you
other questions
representative horgan
um thank you very much mr chair and
thank you very much uh mr cronin and mr
green um
so i've seen your i've seen your sign
i've seen your sign on the door in the
first door of the uh first floor of the
london home gymnasium but never actually
seen you till today
and probably because you're working so
hard um
this um
this bill is a uh this bill is a
perennial i think it's been around as
long as i've been a member of the
legislature since 14 years and
um it seems like the uh rationale for
the rationale against it uh against
licensing agents in the past was
supposedly that it's unnecessary because
so few athletes are signing
pro-contracts from new hampshire um
and um
and now suddenly it's been flipped the
other way around so now we're we're
cutting off a great uh because of the
nao and they i'll change this which is a
major change the ncaa rules now suddenly
we're cutting off this great growth
opportunity so
and actually get to a question here of
course um
so with the traditional function of the
athlete's agents um how pervasive how
how critical is that to a university
university like unh which uh
does have uh
usually does produce a few pro hockey
players every year but in a football
player every ten five or ten years but
you know the basketball program for
example is
except for an assistant coach who became
a head coach in the nba we've never had
anybody affiliated with the program make
it to the nba although certainly is
there a question there yes so how
um how many
athletes agents are you know trolling
around the campus of unh and other new
hampshire-based institutions looking for
clients and uh where would those clients
be be playing if they were placed in a
professional job so
i would say that while you don't see a
tremendous number of unh student
athletes playing and as you pointed out
for example the nba a couple in the nfl
certainly several in the nhl primarily
uh it's actually european for us for
both men's and women's basketball and
men's and women's hockey um where they
do go professionally overseas and and
there are agents involved in that
process
thank you and i've i've seen those
agents sitting in the stands at the
gymnasium in fact so um
okay any other questions
i guess this is just a
a softball for you probably but
yeah we we register lobbyists
here so we know who's getting paid for
providing their services
we
register real estate agents so people
can feel comfortable that
the person at least has some level of
skill
and
i know you uh representative ukela and
you mentioned that
the application registration process
might
form some type of barrier
but do you think it also provides some
protection for the students
yes for certainly um
and honestly
at the risk of in any way undermining
argument i think there is a question
that we would have should agents become
more prevalent in this state what the
state can do to perhaps better enforce
the statute as written if we if we do
leave it on the books i think we have at
least one example of a student
a former student who went on to become
an agent paid the fee did what the state
asked him to do but then was
largely heard saw nothing from the state
in follow-up so to the degree that the
ncaa continues to open the door to these
opportunities
this is a piece of law that we think
really could protect students and
student athletes and institutions of
higher education in the state
if appropriately enforced
i just had one other follow-up and that
is is there any res there's
no
restrictions or limits on liability for
agents
and that i'm aware of is
are you aware of any reason why a
student today could not file suit
against an agent if
they were
if they were caused harmed by the
agent's activities
i wouldn't think so i'll let sean
comment i guess the one thing is it's
not specifically enumerated in statute
the way uh the opportunity for an
institution to do so is
right i do think that there is certainly
an opportunity for a student athlete
who's been harmed who potentially lost
eligibility because of the actions of an
agent to uh to pursue that um that's one
of the pieces that i think we like here
is that representative uk has added that
in specifically in this um but i
i'm not an expert on the law when it
comes to that aspect of things so i
don't know under the current law if they
would be able to do that but i think
they could
thank you
that's it thank you for your testimony
today thank you thank you
i don't have any other pink cards is
there anyone else who would like to
testify on house bill 1023 today
seeing no one will close the hearing on
house bill 1023
and we'll move on to our next item of
business which is a hearing scheduled
for 10 o'clock and house bill 1034
relative to the definition of an
employee or official of a governmental
unit
and
i don't think i have a pink card yet but
representative boyd
you are the prime and at this point in
time only sponsor of the bill and we'll
call upon you to provide your testimony
thank you mr chairman and
show you to my extended colleagues of
the general report
my name is bill boyd representative in
hillsborough representing district 21 in
merrimack
representing house bill 1034 relative to
the definition of employee or official
of the governmental union
this issue was brought to me by my
constituent robert bevel
he's watching this bill
on behalf of him
to
codify
into statute a supreme court decision
from 2007 involving everett versus a
general electric company
one short of it is there is language
that the core clarified regarding
language as it relates to municipal
immunity which
i close reporting
we hope that municipal police officers
are immune from personal liability for
decisions
or missions that are
one made within the scope of their
official duties of
ii
discretionary rather than ministerial in
three not made in a want or reckless
manner
caution against a formal aid approach to
discerning discretionary
and ministerial decisions acts or
remissions
period
and that's a direct site from the 2000
enhancer supreme court case of recovery
excuse me everett versus uh general
undercover so
my constituent is much more well-versed
on what he is seeking to accomplish
as i stated on the sponsor institute for
him
um by the bus
normally i'll stay and answer any
the right questions to be talking
my constituent is here today he is
prepared to testify he's also prepared
to answer any questions
that the committee may have regarding
the legislation
any questions for representative boyd
uh representative boyd do you have
written testimony looks like you were
reading
uh basically it's notes that i have it's
just prepared notes
no need
are there any other questions for
representative boyd
see none thank you for your testimony i
do did you do a pink card yes um
yes i did okay thank you mr chairman
thank you thank you you're welcome
next we have
robert bevel
good morning mr chairman
christian colleagues
uh thank you for hearing me today i have
prepared a testimony
and that it has a comma that is
misplaced
the comma should be removed after
discretionary and placed after
ministerial in order for the sentence to
make sense
yes
can you just turn on your microphone so
thank you that might help there we go
now i don't have to shout thank you very
much
i have the radio voice sorry my name is
uh bob bevel i'm a resident of merrimack
new hampshire representative bill boyd
also of merrimack sponsored this bill
for me in the hopes of bringing rsa 507b
bodily injury actions against government
units into compliance under current case
law
by amending the definitions paragraph of
the statute we can hope to eliminate
further ambiguity or frustration of
purpose when citizens in file tort
actions against the appropriate state
actors for bodily injury
on the whole rsa507b has confusing
stipulations defined within his
paragraphs
and making heads or tales as to which
state actors have immunity is very
difficult to unravel at this time
some sections when read together could
be read as prohibiting any claim that
we're not based on municipal's use of
vehicles or premises
of course if the statute were read that
way it would lead to the unreasonable
sort of quote blanket immunity unquote
that was struck down by the supreme
court in merrell versus manchester
nevertheless state actors have seized
upon the confusing language of the
statute on an attempt to shield
themselves from liability
the supreme court recognizes that quote
leaving an injured citizen exposed
without resource is foreign to the
spirit of our constitutional guarantee
and that every subject is entitled to a
legal remedy for injuries he may receive
in his person or property unquote
if state actors are allowed to argue
that rsa 507 b5 allows them complete and
total immunity from negligence claims
then rsa 507b as read becomes
constitutional because it violates the
state constitution for remedy and equal
protection simply because quote the
defendant is a municipality unquote
the court has previously concluded that
municipalities are subject to the same
rules of liability as private
corporations so technically there should
be no ambiguity
however several supreme court decisions
uh the court has lost sight of its own
rulings
but to redeem itself in fairly versus
city of concord the court noted that
quote it has not interpreted 507b as
completely occupying the field of
municipal immunity so as to preempt the
common law doctrine
and in everett versus general electric
the court set to distinguish the
difference between qualified immunity
and official immunity
the everett court quotes on that quote
the goal of official immunity is to
protect public officials from the fear
of personal liability which might deter
independent action and impair effective
performance in their duties unquote
so how do we resolve the ambiguities of
rsa 507b without creating a
constitutional crisis and without
rewriting the entire statute
the supreme court has been signaling the
legislature in several of its rulings
looking for this clarification
the new hampshire supreme court has
consistently held that the municipal
immunity in rs-75507b
is based on planning or discretionary
functions and not on ministerial
functions
and what is most important is the court
strongly points out that our
rsa
chapter 507b does not address
discretionary or ministerial function
immunity anywhere
so what is the difference between
discretionary decisions and ministerial
one
again we turn to the decision in everett
wherein the court states quote a
discretionary decision act or omission
involves the exercise of personal
deliberation and individual professional
judgment
that necessarily reflects the facts of
the situation
and the professional goal
an official's decision act or a mission
that is ministerial is when it is
absolute certain and imperative
involving merely execution of a specific
duty from fixed and designated facts
under rsa 507 b1 1a the definition of
quote an employee or official of a
governmental unit includes
selectmen school board members city
councilman alderman and such similarly
elected or appointed employees or
officials
in the mayoral decision the court
recognized the distinction that
discretionary function immunity was
still afforded to those state officials
for quote acts or omissions constituting
a
the ex the exercise of legislative or
just judicial function such as we have
here
and b the exercise of a basic policy
decision which is characterized by the
exercise of a high degree of official
judgment or discretion unquote from
merrell
again remember that rsa chapter 507b
does not currently address discretionary
or ministerial function
immunity only the courts have addressed
it
most recently an effort the court
clarified to whom municipal immunity was
entitled
stating that quote accordingly we hold
that municipal police officers are
immune from personal liability for
decisions acts or omissions that are
won
made within the scope of their official
duties while in the course of their
employment
comma two
discretionary rather than ministerial
comma
and three
not made in a wanton or reckless manner
that's everett at 219.
so how do we resolve the ambiguities of
rsa 507b in order to simplify which
state actors are entitled to immunity in
the first place
i propose that the legislature repair
this confusion by simply narrowing the
definition of state actors defined under
this statute based on the court's
previous interpretations in the five
cases i've listed
therefore i have asked that house bill
103 for be approved to amend rsa
b1 1a to include the following phrase
provided he or she
one is acting within the scope of his or
her official duties to
and is in his
her decisions acts or omissions are
discretionary rather than
ministerial
comma and three not made in a wanton or
reckless manner such as in the language
in everett versus general electric
company
one final point i wish to leave with you
and if as some state actors would have
you believe that rsa 507b grants all
state employees complete immunity from
liability for tort claims against them
then why do municipalities pave into the
pooled risk liability insurance when you
purchase a home or auto insurance you
expect to be able to collect on your
damages
in fact if the law said that you didn't
that no one could sue you you'd quit
paying for life insurance or for car
insurance
the fact municipalities continue to
purchase liability insurance is their
tacit submission that they are indeed
liable for those state actors whose
actions or inactions are ministerial or
are made in a wanton or reckless manner
and are not immune from legal remedies
for injuries that may have they may have
caused thank you for your consideration
questions for mr bevel
see none thank you very much thank you
mayor president
yes
thank you
the next person would be
is attorney grace
representing the new hampshire municipal
association
we oppose uh
hb 1034
i did submit written testimony online
so hopefully you have received that
our reading of this bill is that it
would
limit the immunity given to
municipal employees and officials
by
shifting the immunity to simply
discretionary function immunity rather
than the broader
authori broader immunity currently
granted under rsa 507b1
and subsequent statutes or subsequent uh
sections of that chapter i should say
and
we understand we understand that
this is a very complicated area
it is something that's been subject to
several court opinions
defining exactly
what the immunity is that the
legislature granted but
effectively
what this statute
what this bill would do is
no long it would eliminate the
immunity provisions in statute for
officials and employees doing their
day-to-day activities
and
shift the focus entirely on to
the policy making portions of those
rather than
how the statute currently functions
which is to allow a broader immunity
um and so that would
that would potentially cause
greater liability on the part of
municipalities and therefore we oppose
the bill
i'm happy to take any questions
questions
if
i understood you correctly
and just as you summarized you ended
you indicated that this would create a
broader immunity
no i'm sorry uh
the
bill would limit the immunity
provided to municipal officials and
employees
sorry if i misstated that
maybe i just misheard
any other questions
thank you for your testimony today thank
you
marissa chase
excuse me
yeah
just turn on your mic
good morning members of the committee
thank you for allowing me to testify
today my name is marissa chase i'm the
executive director for the new hampshire
association for justice
which is a statewide trial associate
statewide trial lawyers association
our members have
a wide variety of practice areas
and
it's interesting because this is not the
testimony i thought i would be giving
today
when our members read this bill we
thought it codified and expanded the
holding in everett
but it seems that
mr the attorney who first spoke the
constituent of representative boyd
everything he said we completely agree
with
we just think that this bill is very
confusing our reading of it was that
again it expanded immunity
and the municipal association
clearly has a different view of it i
think that just goes to show how
confusing this whole statutory framework
in rsa 507b is
i mean our members would like to see it
repealed completely
understanding that probably won't happen
but
we
we really got hung up with the
difference of provided or unless
provided currently in the statute this
bill changed this bill um
you know we
would say unless would be a better a
better word
than provided as currently in the
statute before the changes the bill
seeks to make
because the underlying problem with rsa
507b is that as interpreted by the new
hampshire supreme court it does insulate
public employers from common law
liability for intentional or reckless
actions
but if you think of a ministerial duty
think of a school bus driver employed by
you know the town
they have to
strap in a handicapped child to a car
seat
what if they don't do that then to avoid
a crash the school bus driver slams on
their brakes the child is severely
injured there's no accountability we
believe under this bill
as it as our reading of it is that it
applies to ministerial actions as well
i don't believe that's the intent at all
especially after hearing from the first
speaker but would happy to work with any
party on this to um
get some clarity to 507b
questions for
ms chase
it's it's a confused very confusing area
of law
seeing no questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1034
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill 1034.
and we are i expected we'd have a lot
more
testimony on that today
given the history of the issue
so our next hearing is scheduled for 11
o'clock when the committee will be in
recess until 11 o'clock
i didn't understand
justice is
that's a ministerial duty
and it should absolutely be covered i
mean they should be subject to us
should he personally
maybe
maybe oh he's going to make
i was totally confused by the time we
were
good morning again we'll call the house
judiciary committee back to order
and our
first
item of business
is
a
hearing on house bill
1036 the prime sponsor is representative
wolper and representative will call upon
representative wilper to introduce the
bill and provide his testimony
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
house bill 1036 is uh one of the most
uh um
i would want to call i
want to call it an unnecessary bill but
it's not unnecessary
because
i was contacted by
a public employee
who was seriously
abused
by violations of the right to know act
which already
says
that a public employee has the right to
be notified
and to attend
and even to request open hearings and be
represented
at a meeting a closed meeting
which is affecting that person or about
that person
and this individual was denied all of
that
and and abused in the process but we i
don't you don't need to go down that
rabbit trail
right the fact is that the law was was
violated and it was in a serious way and
in our discussion
i said to him so what do you want me to
do about it
[Laughter]
i mean this is a done deal what do you
want me to do
and he said well
what can you do i said well how about if
we just reword
the sentence that's already there
to make it clearer
what's required
and so all i did was i took the sentence
in the existing law
and instead of saying you're supposed to
notify the republic the individual has
the right to be notified
i said no much such meaning shall occur
unless the person is notified
there you go
that's it and it's just an attempt to
strengthen
the language not to change any of the
requirements doesn't do that
it just puts it in a little stronger
sense
and so that's what that's why the bill
is here before you
any questions for representative wolper
representative sylvia
so my question
this
section of 91a
appears to be about
public employees
and
yet i recall an incident where
under
that listing of a
i was mentioned in a non-public meeting
so is this to be read to be exclusively
about public employees
so
thank you for the
question the answer to your question is
in the amendment that i emailed you this
morning
which adds similar
language
to another
part of the 91a
to cover individuals private individuals
so those private individuals will have
the same protections
that public employees get
thank you and um
i think that the the lawyers in the room
would probably um
ask about uh notifying and what sort of
time frame uh
notice
would require do you have a concept of
that
i would prefer that the notification
period were
somewhat longer
there's none there
but i recognize that
in at least some of these i can easily
envision cases
where the notification period would be
necessarily quite short
and so i didn't add a time
reference in it
thank you
representative horgan
thank you very much mr chair thank you
mr member
um and
actually i have not
seen the uh seen the amendment i was
probably busy waking up and driving to
concord when he sent it out but um
and i guess that applies to the part the
other party added like what happened
what do we do
if there's good reason for not telling
the
employee or the other person in fans
maybe because they're
threatening another person maybe they
maybe they might be dangerous if they
knew they were about to be fired or
disciplined or what if they're pulling
some
well if they're putting some some some
scam and you need to catch them unaware
say if they're embezzling money or
whatever so
um
this seems to leave no exception for
cases uh where there's a good reason for
not
not informing the uh employees so that
was it was that your intent to
eliminate such meetings or
or do you feel there's a safeguard
somewhere else the law or are you or do
you need to amend the bill again so like
what's your response to that because as
i said there are
often good reasons why you want to meet
to talk about somebody before you let
him know that he's being talked about
just so
especially when you're dismissing
somebody which can be a very emotional
very dangerous
moment thanks
so
uh all i can say to you is
i changed nothing
in the existing statute
in terms of
anything all i did was reword the
existing sentence so if you think that
there should be some additional
exemption
right now the law is blanket it says a
person shall be notified
before you have the meeting and has
rights
and that's exactly what it says after
my bill is adopted it says the person
should be notified and has rights
the difference only difference is mine
says you cannot have the meeting
unless you've met the requirements of
the law
right which is really what the other one
meant too
it just says it in a stronger way
other questions
um representative lorenzo thank you mr
chairman um representative walper
i thought that a few minutes ago
i heard in this room that
this would cover private
people
uh yes i sent you an amendment this
morning okay that would
establish the private individuals are
not currently
protected in the law in this way
this is only for public employees
so my amendment
actually does add the protections for
private individuals
okay i don't see that i have the
amendment in front of me
if you have if all you're doing is
looking at the bill it won't be there
because it's in i'm looking at the
amendment you're reading the amendment
yes yes thank you
are you all set representative yes thank
you
any other questions
see none thank you for your testimony
today
nature grace
thank you mr chair nate grays for the
new hampshire municipal association
i have not seen the amendment uh that
representative wolfer uh spoke about it
does not appear to be on the website yet
um
preliminarily i will say that we are
more likely than not to object to the
amendment
extending um
this kind of uh
process to private individuals but as i
haven't seen it i can't speak
definitively
um as far as the introduced bill
i
nhma is neither for it nor against it we
read it
as representative walter
uh
proposed it which is that it simply
clarifies the language um
and the way this functions now is that
if a
public employee
has a right to a meeting and
presumably the governing body but
whatever
body is meeting about them
to regard the dismissal promotion
compensation
disciplining or investigation of charges
is going to meet and that would
implicate the right to a meeting
that employee is supposed to be noticed
and have a right to attend and allow
that meeting or i guess request that the
meeting be an open meeting rather than a
non-public session occurring at the
meeting um so it wouldn't change the way
that the law functions
um it would just clarify some of that
language
happy to take questions
any questions questions for attorney
grace
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
the next person to testify is
lori
ortilano
do you each have one yeah
my name is lori ordolano i live in
nashua i'm vice president for right to
know new hampshire
right to know new hampshire is
supporting h.b 1036 with an amendment
which would require citizens to be
notified if they wish to participate in
a non-public meeting when it involves
their reputation we are requesting that
the law change this amendment apply to
rsa 91 dash a colon 3 section c
matters which affect the reputation of
others other than
section a which
in addition to section a which was
originally proposed i became actively
involved in the work done by the nashua
assessing office questioning the
practices and consistency of assessments
created through right-to-know requests
prior to attending board of assessor
meetings the board rarely entered
non-public session or produced any
records of such meetings in 2019
non-public sessions became a regular
occurrence once i started going and now
the board spends two-thirds of their
meeting time in non-public session
100 of the 2021 meetings of which there
were 20 had a non-public session using
exemption c
matters which likely would affect the
reputation of others i believe a number
of these sessions involved matters that
could affect my reputation and involved
my request for information and research
in the office i have never been notified
by the board to request an open meeting
on this matter
boards often operate at the behest of
the administration and can be kept in
the dark on
certain citizen issues
these non-public sections lack about a
lack balanced perspective
my preference would be to be notified
when discussions regarding my reputation
are the topic of a non-public session
and be given the choice for the public
meeting for a public meeting or
to participate in that public session
so i've attached amended a language to
section c
of um
rsa 91a colon 3
which is matters which if discussed in
public would likely
adversely affect adversely the
reputation of any person other than a
member of the public body itself unless
such person requests an open meeting
that's the standing language we're
adding a person may request a non-public
session if they believe a topic will
affect their reputation the person to be
discussed by the board shall be notified
in writing at least 48 hours prior to
the non-public session provided that
notification may be waived upon written
agreement of the parties such person
shall be afforded the opportunity to a
be present at the session during
discussions and decisions which involve
the person b have counsel or a
representative of his or her own
choosing present and attending for the
purpose of advising the individual and
not for the purpose of active
participation in the session three speak
on his or her own behalf
d
that was c
at the person's option record the
session by auto recording for or
transcription at the person's expense
um item three was added that contractors
of bid business can't participate in a
non-public session based on issues of
reputation
so
um
and that last item was just added
because we were concerned that if by
chance
a municipality has bid work out
um
that if they um
invited one bidder in to discuss
something without in a non-public
session and didn't do it for another it
would be an unfair advantage and bid
business is different in that it's a
financial matter
to advance
the municipality on a project so we
didn't want to see this become an issue
of having bidders in these non-public
sessions it's really more geared towards
citizens that are concerned
um
so i mean our our non-public sessions
have gone up tremendously every board
meeting
literally two-thirds of the meeting is
now non-public
and since 2019
um
2020 and 2021 there has not been a set
of minutes unsealed
when they're spending 30 40 an hour an
hour and a half in a non-public nothing
comes out of it even if contract
negotiations are finalized on
let's say property appeals
and the um representative who asked
about
you know what do you do when you have
somebody
who might pose a risk or has been
threatening
that
wants to be in this meeting well as the
law is written now an employee under
section i think a is allowed to be there
whatever risk they um
you know present um that
those terms really cover union employees
who can have a union representative come
in to address uh a matter in non-public
that affects their reputation and
ultimately their job as an employee but
if a
organization feels threatened or
concerned by an employee that has been
in a scuffle let's say at work and is
being terminated i don't see what
precludes them from having a police
officer present in the room if they fear
for their safety there would be a
mechanism there but the law right now
allows these individuals no matter wow
you know
if they're still gainfully employed and
in the building to be part of that
hearing i suppose if they were arrested
and thrown in jail that wouldn't be
happening but
if they're gainfully employed
you know your personal feeling of a
threat
has to be dealt with in a different
manner than denying them
their right to be present in a meeting i
think
questions for ms bordellano
sing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
and i
yes sir
the
we will hear from
barrett christina
thank you chairman gordon thank you
members of the committee barrett
christine executive director of the new
hampshire school boards
i apologize for handing in my card later
i was not planning on testifying on this
bill but some of the conversation made
me want to clarify a couple of things
first nhsb is not taking a position on
on this bill per se i have not seen the
amendments um from representative walper
or from uh
ms ordolano
with near capacity representing
right to know new hampshire uh i do want
to cause the committee to be very
cautious
about some of the language and the right
to know law and what some of the
meanings may particularly be
um
specifically as it relates to the
non-public session statute
paragraph a speaks to employee having a
right to a meeting
nhsba has always taken the position that
that language to some degree has been
inappropriate
nobody has a right to a meeting what you
may have a right to is a hearing
which may be held in an open meeting or
a non-public session the right to a
hearing has to be based under statutory
law
the constitution per se administrative
rules or perhaps a school board policy
may grant
a parent or a student a hearing before a
particular school board
the other concern that nhs so that's one
concern with with with paragraph a which
talks to a right to a meeting again you
don't necessarily have a right to a
meeting you have a right to a hearing
and the impacted person the student or
the employee
in a school context has the choice of
having that an
open meeting or a non-public session
second relative to paragraph c
the reputation provision again i would
caution this committee
to be mindful about requiring a public
body to invite the person that the
public body is going to be speaking
about if that person's reputation is
going to be impacted by way of example
there is nothing in the right to know
law the non-public chess the non-public
session statute
that speaks specifically about a school
board addressing student matters under a
non-public session because that
student's reputation is being impacted
so student disciplinary matters are all
we we advise our school boards to use
paragraph c for all student disciplinary
matters whatever that discipline may be
it seems very peculiar that in the
initial stages of an investigation
a student is alleged to have been
selling drugs a student is alleged to
have been engaged in some sort of
wrongdoing on school grounds where the
superintendent
the principal need to inform the school
board need to perhaps have the attorney
there because an investigation needs to
be done it seems very peculiar that we
would invite the alleged into that
non-public session when the school board
the superintendent
and perhaps an attorney perhaps an
investigator
need to formulate the scope of how
they're going to proceed with that
particular incident so nhsb would be
very very would ask this community to be
very very cautious about commit
about including anything in the
non-public session statute that would
require the impacted person whose
reputation
who the board may be talking about to be
allowed into that conversation it would
significantly inhibit public bodies from
investigating taking discipline against
perhaps employees speaking with
investigators and things of that nature
so to the bill itself again we're not
taking a position on it but
hearing the conversation with some of
these amendments i i felt it prudent to
provide this committee information about
one the difference between a mirror a
meeting and a hearing and two some of
the reasons why we may not want to um
allow
the the impacted individual into the
non-public session when the public body
needs to sort of sort these things out
initially and i'll conclude my testimony
and i'm happy to take any questions
are there any questions for mr christina
the only question i have is the language
in the statute that's being amended
specifically refers to a meeting in this
case so are you suggesting that
that this bill be used to change
the language which was previously
adopted by the legislature
thank you for the question mr chair um
you know it it
possibly it's one of those things in the
school context we've just sort of lived
with it and provided legal advice in a
manner that
that we thought made sense within the
the constraints of of of the statute so
um i mean i hadn't thought about an
amendment if you would be willing to
entertain that i can certainly work on
something with our staff attorney and
perhaps bring nhma in into the fold as
well too
we could certainly make a suggestion
all right thank you very much sir
any
anybody else have questions
see none thank you thank you very much
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 1036
seeing none
now we'll close the hearing on house
bill 1036
and the committee will be in recess
until our next hearing which is
scheduled for one o'clock
thank you everybody
um
okay
uh
right
yep
hmm
okay
oh my gosh
yes
okay
i could go home
all right
there's no
is
yeah i can do that
i don't want to hit mike
uh
it being one o'clock we'll
call the house judiciary committee to
order
our first item of business is a hearing
this afternoon on house bill 12 91
and i will call upon representative
kenny to who is the prime sponsor to
introduce the bill and provide his
testimony
alrighty thank you mr chairman and
members of judiciary
my name is cam kenny
i am the prime sponsor of this bill i
represent durham and madbury which of
course includes the university of new
hampshire
so i'm here to um introduce hb 1291.
um so first the bill is only 14 lines so
i'll just go over it briefly
uh lines three to about half of five
speaks to the intention of the bill
which is that a prospective tenant who
participates in the housing choice
voucher program
cannot be denied
for the sole purpose of being a
participant in this program
this is commonly known as a section 8
choice voucher
lines seven through thirteen provide
two reasons where denying a prospective
tenant would not be in violation
lines seven through nine carves out the
first instance with the rent charged
for the unit is above that which the
housing authority can approve so long as
the rent price is comparable with
similar units
lines 11 through 13 discuss the second
exception which is instances that the
dwelling fails to meet the housing
quality standards so
not only do we have those two instances
carved up where you would not be in
violation but nothing prohibits the
landlord to continue their screening
policies that all other applicants would
go through
i mean it can take five years or more
to secure a voucher depending on family
side possible disabilities and other
various potential hardships
i i will send the committee an nhpr
article
with multiple personal testimonies in
situations of long waiting periods even
eight to nine years
to make it to the top of the waiting
list
after these low-income families make it
to the top of the list it is typical
that they will lose the voucher because
they cannot find a landlord who will
accept it
it is not uncommon that listing for
rentals
will specify that they do not accept
section 8 choice vouchers
it is more than reasonable that
landlords should not be permitted to
deny low-income families who are in
desperate need of housing just because
they hold one of these vouchers there's
a stigma
that we do need to change
but you will hear other testimonies
after me
i don't want to repeat what they will
say so i will wrap it up i am happy to
answer any questions but
there are experts and like i said
personal testimonies who will be
following me if i cannot answer any of
those questions thank you mr chairman
thank you
any questions for representative kenny
cnn thank you for your testimony today
thank you
representative horrigan
thank you very much rep
representative gordon and thank you very
much i guess you're thank you very much
mr chair and you're
um so uh
revenue kenny covered it uh pretty well
so i probably have nothing to add but
i'll add something anyway
anyway it's section eight first of all
it's a federal program created in the
mid 70s um
i think it was during
the uh presidency of richard m nixon
who's not exactly known as a
not exactly known as a flaming liberal
although
and it's uh
the services are provided by local
public housing authorities which here in
new hampshire exist only in certain
towns and cities but the hampshire
housing finance authority does provide
statewide
oversight of section 8 programs and uh
does
the program does serve tenants who live
in towns other than those view which has
a which have a housing authority which
is mostly
mostly the larger ones but a few smaller
ones which do my
german madbury do neither them have a
housing authority there's one in dover
but there are some subsidized housing
even in our community
and um
as was already mentioned the choice
housing choice voucher premiums it's
very popular with the tenants in fact
the latest is so long in many areas you
can't even get on the list and
then once ironically once you get the
voucher then that you'll have a few
months to find a place to rent and um
and uh these
vouchers are intended for tenants who
wish to try to rent a uh i guess a
non-subsidized
non-sub subsidized development there's
many that were subsidized with a um
with the tax the tax credit or other
programs in fact there's some landlords
who do nothing but build section 8
eligible housing but um but that doesn't
apply those are separate uh vouchers for
those
and uh you're gonna
um you're going to hear a lot of
anecdotes
and um
about how bad the tenants are and a
small percentage of sectioning tenants
are bad but this is true of all tenants
subsidized as well as unsubsidized and
actually the actual data
that the housing and urban development
farm and housing for element is made
made available tends to show that the
tenants are preferable to non-voucher
tenants they are more likely to pay
their rent on time
partially because some of it is being
paid on time by uh
the local housing authority they take
better care of their units and they stay
longer they stay on average of eight and
three-quarters years which is much
longer than most tenants stay so
and we're also going to hear about the
bureaucracy and actually
it is true that section 8 tenants have
more guaranteed rights and more
enforceable rights than regular tenants
and
the uh the housing authorities do um
defend those rights pretty zealously in
many cases and sometimes
but um
sometimes hud does too but that's not a
bad thing the section 8 housing
standards are detailed but
the reasonable and common sensical um
there's just uh
there's nothing on there that every
every tenant regardless of whether or
not they qualify for a voucher uh should
be getting as a matter of course it's
just um there's a mechanism a place for
enforcing
those standards and those rights which
other tenants don't have and that's uh
and that's so that's uh i think this is
a uh
i think this is a good bill it'll
actually help i think all tenants
because uh
the things the inspectors
um talk about as i said as i said
there's things every tenant should have
and probably that would probably make
the landlords more uh
more aggressive about maintaining those
standards in their other units too so
that's uh
you know anyway so that that's that's
what i have to add add to it so i also
urge you to pass the bill so and also
a lot of these anecdotes which we may or
may not be hearing i think we probably
will be
just trying to listen to them listen to
respectfully but try to figure out if
you figure just try to
figure out what's being left out because
i'm in previous hearings lots of times
they'd say these things and they thought
it was a sectioning tenant sometimes not
sure they're not sure who came to
inspect it and not quite sure when these
things happened and uh
you know just
that's just something i urge the
committee to be be sensitive to so
um
this is this isn't this is a this is an
excellent program and uh it should be
protected thanks
thank you any questions for
representative horrigan yes yes
representative sylvia
thank you mr chairman thank you for uh
taking my question
um
chapter 354a
is the human rights commission
and they are protecting
those
[Music]
inhabitants
because of age sex gender identity race
color
creed marital status familial status
physical or mental disability or
national origin
how does a voucher fit into that
category of protected classes
it doesn't
quite fit in there but the body uh has
other duties other than enforcing that
laundry list of uh protected classes and
this would be uh
actually have the bill and the rsa
referred to right in front of me this
would add a new paragraph 1a right after
so
so roman numeral
so roman numeral 1 is just an
introduction um
and actually there are some
there already is some stuff about
rentals in there anyway so this is uh
decided to put in a separate paragraph
but that's uh that's the intent of it so
that's the body that would uh
enforce the complaints if the
tenants and landlord were unable to come
to agreement through through other means
and
disputes are usually going to be about
things that happen between other
landlords and other tenants too and then
pretty much
as i said before the standards in there
are pretty commonsensical there's just
not
just most uh tenants don't don't have
anyone to help them enforce them but
these are all like fairly standard
standard things that the landlord is
expected to do even though not all do
them all the time so they
representative lorenzo did you have a
question
thank you mr chairman um
representative horrigan
um would you say that there's a lot of
misinformation about the section 8
program um absolutely and i'll try to
help to dispel some of my handing around
a fact sheet that hud uh
prints up
and
i uh
and actually if you look at the hud
website they have an excellent youtube
video with a conversation between a
small landlord and a slightly bigger
landlord and the
slightly bigger landlord is telling the
homeowner who has like an extra unit
why it's a good thing to participate in
and of course although that's somewhat
different
housing market in the fictional scenario
in that youtube because they sort of
seem that uh
for example that it's
difficult to find tenants i talk about
how it's easier
is another avenue you can reach out to
find potential tenants which i'm pretty
sure our landlords here in answering
many problems but finding potential
tenants is probably pretty low in their
list at the moment but
thank you thank you
other questions for representative
horrigan
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you it got off easy thanks
representative gabby grossman
good afternoon
chairman gordon and honorable members of
the judiciary committee
my name is representative gabby grossman
serving in rockingham district 18
exeter i am co-chair of the bipartisan
disability caucus
an independent business owner of
amesbrook campground in ashland new
hampshire with my husband
i'm a mother to three teenage boys
artist and advocate
i'm here today to speak on behalf of the
disability community and to ask your
support of hb 1291
prohibiting discrimination against
tenants using house choice vouchers
as the mother of a young man who
experiences autism it is my greatest
hope that he will experience as much
independence as possible in his
community as he transitions to adulthood
the housing choice voucher program in
new hampshire is a critical piece
to a complex system
of ensuring that people with
disabilities can be productive members
of their home communities
hb 1291 would help remove discriminatory
housing practices in our state
most new hampshire residents will
experience a disability at some point
during their lives either personally or
within their families
we must protect the vision and integrity
of rsa 171 a
new hampshire's groundbreaking law
establishing community-based supports
and services
closing institutions in new hampshire
helping to pass hb 1291 is one way that
we can ensure that we continue to
support our new hampshire citizens that
experience a disability
currently we are experiencing a critical
shortage for workforce housing in new
hampshire that affects members of the
disability community
according to able new hampshire's 2021
housing survey
70 percent of both family caretakers and
individuals with disabilities in new
hampshire reported a need for access to
supportive accessible housing
and 68 percent of family caretakers
stated their loved one is presently at
risk of homelessness
it is our responsibility as lawmakers to
work together to build healthy and
strong communities that remove
discriminatory housing practices
thank you for your time and i hope that
you will move ought to pass for this
important bill for the disability
community thank you so much
questions for representative grossman
see none thank you for your testimony
today
the next speaker would be elliot berry
and i just would note that i have a
commitment to testify upstairs and i'm
going to turn the gavel over to
representative sylvia to run the rest of
the here
you'd think i'd know that by now thank
you
thank you it's good to be back before
the committee my name is elliott berry
uh i've been a attorney at new hampshire
legal assistance for over 40 years where
i've done an enormous amount of work and
probably most aspects of housing law
i have a few handouts with um
and i just want to run through
uh the first one
just gives you a little background about
where we're at
we have a housing market in which the
median rent is
including utilities is 1
498 for a two-bedroom apartment a
vacancy rate of less than one percent
and the most staggering figure of all 27
more than 27 000 people
households in new hampshire are paying
more than half of their income for rent
so
the section 8 voucher program you have
it's
geared for people of a low income
largely people at 50 percent of median
income for the state or less
most people
who get these vouchers have been waiting
for the voucher for over five years
many of those people are the same people
who are paying over half their income
for rent and what happens when they do
that
they get they fall behind they get
evicted and then when they go to apply
for a new apartment
the question is have you been evicted
and the answer is yeah i was paying more
than half of my income for rent
so they just get into a cycle of
eviction and homelessness
so the tenant is guaranteed in the
program to pay or i should say in the
overwhelming majority of cases because
of this federal subsidy that comes
through local and state housing
authorities the tenant pays 30 percent
of their income for shelter and
utilities
and the housing authority pays the rest
of the the rest of the contract rent
is a public housing authority
creates a something called a payment
standard
which is mostly set at about 110 percent
of the fair market rent
uh and what the landlord has to do to be
to continue to get paid is to keep the
property up to hud's fair uh a hud's uh
housing quality standards
the what's
important to know about this is that the
housing quality standards aren't all
that different than what the local house
the
city of manchester the city of nashua
the local housing codes are very very
similar
and we also have the state law about you
know dealing with lead but it's a good
deal for landlords
because the rent
is all most of the rent is guaranteed if
the tenant misses a payment it's usually
a small portion of the contract rent so
even if the tenant doesn't pay the
housing authority is going to pay most
of the
uh most of the price
so here's the problem
the vouchers are generally good for 60
days with a right to an extension for 30
days and perhaps another 30-day
extension
we have we have personally conducted a
survey of most of the housing
authorities in the state including the
new hampshire housing finance authority
which runs by far the largest in the
state
we found that
over the past year these authorities and
and there's a chart in the materials
that i gave you
they issued
1581 vouchers over the last uh in 2021
and
294 of them expired that means that the
holder of the voucher couldn't find any
landlord who was willing to take them
and that so after waiting five years or
more for that voucher they're right back
into the cycle of not being able to
afford the rent and the cycle of
eviction that invariably follows
let me be really clear about that
could you just repeat that
with the 1591 vouchers were issued in
1581 right and 294 expired
um
how i won't
please understand i know and you need to
know that house bill 1291 will not solve
the problem for all about your holders
there's no question about it there are
other serious reasons why landlords have
good reason
not to participate in the program
the biggest one is that the rents are
too high for what hud will approve or
the local housing authority will approve
in many cases then there are a lot of
tenants who have spotty records and the
bill does not say and this is just
incredibly important the bill doesn't
say you have to rent to all voucher
holders
the bill simply says you can't refuse
them because they're a voucher holder
it's exactly the same thing as the
current
requirement that you can't you can't
reject a person because they're a person
of color or because they have
disabilities or because they're children
or because they have children sorry so
the if the question is or the issue is
the landlord can simply can apply all of
their usual
admission standards that they would
apply to anybody else except they can't
say we're not going to rent to you
because you have a section 8 voucher
the landlord can charge as much rent
with that as they want and the law is
explicit
absolutely explicit that if the rent is
higher than what the housing authority
will approve
you that is not discrimination the law
is or the bill is explicit
that if the
housing if the unit doesn't pass hud's
house and quality standards
that's not discrimination
so
you might ask
well won't landlords still be able to
get around this and the answer is some
will
there's no doubt about it the same way
that there's still disability
discrimination
race discrimination
family status discrimination that all
exists today notwithstanding the law but
you know what
there are a lot of landlords are out
there that if this bill passes they'll
do the right thing because it's the law
and i don't believe that most landlords
are lawless
so i think it
with very with very little downside to
anybody i think the bill can help all
those people who have waited some of
those people who have waited so long to
get that voucher
to finally find secure housing that they
can afford let me just add one other a
couple other things
every state in new england has what they
call source of income discrimination
except us
i made when i
got involved with this bill i made it
more specific to vouchers
people want to expand it to other
sources of income uh they're welcome
number two like
the the discrimination law that's in
effect today 354 a
that uh
representative sylvia referred to all
exempts
owner-occupied units of three three
units or less so your standard triple
decker that landlord who lives in that
building is not covered as is a anybody
who is renting out a single family home
if they're not renting out other single
family homes as well
finally just one thing to note that new
hampshire housing finance authority
which operates the statewide program
section 8 program
over 60 percent i think it's 66 percent
of the people who are the households
that are assisted by this terrific
program are persons with disabilities so
obviously um
the program's making a big difference
um and at the end of the day house bill
1291 will simply give people a chance uh
to get a foot in the door to vouch
holders to get a foot in the door so
that the landlord will evaluate them
based on their inherent characteristics
based on their their tenant record based
on criminal records and everything else
but they get a foot in the door instead
of having it slammed in their face and
saying
no we just don't take section 8.
there's a letter in there from paul
stewart who runs stewart property
management company he manages
2500 units in the state of new hampshire
and he hasn't fully supported the bill
there's other landlords who are as well
and the packet also contained some
letters from people who have been the
victims of the kind of discrimination
that we're talking about i really thank
you for giving me the time that you've
just given me thank you for any
questions for attorney barry uh
representative d lorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
berry i have a question about um
screening
for section 8 applicants
does the housing authority screen people
before
actually represented dealer enzo they
used to when in the early days of the
program uh they don't anymore and they
decided they would leave that up to the
individual landlord okay
thank you
representative simpson
thank you for taking my question um i i
just missed when you said what percent
of users of this voucher have uh
disabilities i dismissed what you said
yeah the um it's at least 60 percent and
this is just of the housing finance
authority new hampshire housings program
but it's by far the biggest in the state
i think they told me 66 but i can
guarantee you it's at least 60 percent
our head the head of the household is a
person with disabilities and that
doesn't count a special allocation
that's only for people with disabilities
that's in their general program
thank you mr chair thank you mr barry
for taking my question
could you tell me um you said that the
vouchers expired at uh 60 and 90 days
with the renewal for 30 days after
is there any particular reason for that
expiration date or i think and again
it's 60 and then 30 30.
some authorities 30 and 30 30 and 30. if
again that's not an entitlement that's
based on whether the authorities think
you've been trying hard enough to get in
another place
but that does tell you when you have
those over 260 what did i say people who
have been expired that means a lot of
them have been over 120 days they still
couldn't find anything the reason for it
i think is that
hud realizes that at some point somebody
else should use the voucher right that
this person is just
you know it's just not going to happen
for them i think you know
i don't really want to speak for hud but
i think that's the motivation behind it
thank you
any further questions
thank you thank you very much attorney
barry
next we'll call uh david klein
who opposes the bill
and uh we have a pretty good stack of
cards and uh
you have signed up for seven minutes if
you could make that a tight seven
minutes we'd appreciate it i'll i will
do the best i can mr chairman thank you
my name is david klein i am speaking and
opposed to the bill i am a landlord
and i currently do have section 8
tenants roughly 15 of my apartments are
rented to
section 8 people
but those people
became my tenants because i made the
choice it wasn't forced upon me i took
on the added burden that section 8
program itself does add to us as
landlords
and there it's clearly more work for us
as a landlord dealing with people on the
housing choice voucher program
than with people who are not and it is
not because of the tenants it's because
of the program itself
renting not only do we they come in with
a voucher we have to confirm the voucher
we do have extra forms we have to
complete
we have to go for the
modify our leases to incorporate by
references the h.a.p the housing
authority
contract which itself is multi-page
fairly complicated to read document
we also become subject to all the rules
and regulations of the housing choice
program however the housing authority
that enforces it does not join the lease
so that if a tenant leaves early
we cannot go back to the housing
authority and say we still are entitled
to rent for the rest of the lease as
with power private tenants
and they say no go chase the tenant
we also find out that i have run into
the situation where i have rules all of
a sudden that come up by the housing
authorities themselves
the handout that i gave you
if you look at i put numbers in the
upper right hand corner number one is a
document that came from mr flanagan the
inspector for the new hampshire housing
finance authority
prior to his starting somewhere around
i had never had any housing authority
ever asked to inspect my boilers my
basements my circuit breakers for the
buildings in the basement
and mr flanagan took it upon himself
decided that he was going to inspect all
of it handed out the letter that i gave
you sent it to me with a request which i
didn't copy that i either be at the
building or in the alternative secondly
that i have to certify to him
that i have complied with it
his idea of my being at the building is
he was going to inspect anywhere between
two and four in the afternoon i don't
have the time or at that time i did not
have the time i was working in excess of
60 hours a week on the buildings to
stand around waiting for him to come by
at his leisure
consequently i have to write them a
letter every year every inspection that
i comply with all of the requirements
set forth in on exhibit one and you'll
see a copy of the letter
um that i prepared as exhibit number two
showing all the things i had to go
through yes it's a letter but it's
another hour of work and when you're
working 60 hours a week it's another
drain on resources that i have
and that's why i say i want to be able
to choose how many i have and who i have
rather than be forced to take them all
also part of section 8 is that we can
have the rent allocation between the
tenant and the housing authority change
time during the lease process
not least process during the lease
itself if you look at exhibits three a b
and c there are letters all regarding
the same tenant
three times in the same period within a
number of months this tenant went in and
out of employment
i have to give him credit with his
disability he did does go back to work
but at the same time it's bookkeeping
it's keeping track of the do different
rents it's more burden on me as a
landlord
to have to do this
i've also had an instance where we had a
woman by the name of lisa and she is
actually still a tenant
we contacted her about renewing the
lease
she agreed to it we contacted a section
eight they pushed us hard to take a
slightly lower rate than the maximum we
agreed to it
we start doing all the lease work lisa
went out and applied to subsidize
housing and thought she was accepted
gave us notice said she wasn't going to
stay with us we constantly put the mark
the unit on the market
had a new tenant had a much higher rent
and then lisa found out there was
something in her background which i
don't remember what it was
that got her denied in the subsidized
housing
now she was facing homelessness
we were agreeing to keep her there we
had to work with the tenant the
prospective tenant who was applied and
we had accepted and we were lucky he
didn't sue us for the difference between
what he
wore it
and we said to section 8 we want the
maximum rent we're helping you out we're
helping the tenant out new hampshire
housing finance said no you accepted the
other rent you're stuck with it they
refuse to do deal with us they refuse to
talk about it
our choice was to throw lisa out and go
through the eviction process or accept
it
the time fighting was a lot lisa is a
nice person i didn't want to do that too
we accepted it but again we took a a
loss financially on this because this
particular new hampshire housing finance
authority person decided we couldn't do
it we couldn't take the regular rent the
the higher rent
there are also other instances that i
can go through where we've had problems
with the housing authorities i'm not
complaining about the tenants i'm
cleaning out the housing authorities but
uh because of the request disabled in
seven minutes i will
i also have
an issue with the construction of the
bill
i know that attorney barry has stated
that
it does not say we are prohibited
from using any other
screening techniques that we have used
in the past
however i do have a problem with it
and i have that problem based on an
interpretation of rsa 540 colon 2 the
eviction statute by the supreme court
it does not say in there we are
prohibited from using the end of a lease
as grounds for an eviction however the
supreme court has clearly ruled that if
a lease is ending you cannot use it as a
grounds for eviction there is a case
directly on point on this
and therefore because the legislature
did not say you can do it we are
prohibiting it because this bill does
not specifically state that we can use
all other
screening techniques i am concerned that
we may have a ruling from the supreme
court and if that comes down we have no
way to screen these people for
a child molester going into a building
with minor children bad rent payments
bad behavior and please understand not
only does screening help us as landlords
screening is very important to the other
tenants because i've had
made a mistake brought in a tenant who
was
totally disturbed everyone in the
building and even called the police on
four of the five other tenants in the
building and called the police on me
twice
and every time the police
they i don't know why they didn't
serve her for filing false complaints
because nothing ever came of all of them
but she was just very very difficult to
do it
i also want to point out the two
categories that you're in there if you
do not want section 8 tenants one of the
ways is higher rents
that means you are now incentivizing 10
landlords to raise rents which hurts not
only the section 8s because they can't
get but everybody else who's in the
moderate income brand looking for
workforce housing because all the rents
are being pushed up even more the other
alternatives allow the building to
deteriorate for the less scrupulous
landlords i will not do that i
don't feel that's appropriate and make
sure you flunk every single housing
housing inspection
the solution is really not forcing us to
take section eight the solution is
building more subsidized housing and
that's where this legislation needs to
go
and i also want to point out that that
we talk about the length of the waiting
list to get the voucher that has nothing
to do with this bill that is because
there's not enough money available for
vouchers that's a federal government
issue
so that cannot be placed on us as
landlords because we have nothing to do
with how that is funded
and for those vouchers that were granted
the 1580 that elliott uh referred to
20 percent roughly little less than 20
percent my quick calculation of those
that did not get apartments how many of
those people was their fault because
they didn't put in the effort to get the
apartments we don't know we will never
know but it isn't as bad of a problem as
making it sound the worst part of the
problem is lack of funding for more
vouchers
i appreciate it if you would vote this
thing to be it expedient to legislate i
don't think it's a good bill i think it
needs more work i think it should be
clarified and i actually don't feel that
it's fair to us that we're being forced
to take tenants when we don't want to
thank you thank you mr klein for your
testimony any questions for mr klein
representative langley
uh thank you mr chair and thank you mr
klein for taking my question mr klein
when you passed out your handouts you
had your exhibit one
was a notice from uh
inspector flynn again
and i i have two questions the first is
do does your local housing does your
local city
require specific ordinances
in terms of uh housing having to meet
specific standards
as far as i know opportunities do and as
as attorney barry said mrs klein could
you speak to the microphone my apologies
they all
most of the cities and towns do when
there is a state statute does have those
requirements yes but no other
section 8 inspector has ever asked for
it and i've dealt with four housing
authorities rochester dover somersworth
in new hampshire housing and new
hampshire housing is the only one that
has come up with this it's a rule that
he himself
came up with not something that i've
seen statewide
so it's is it your testimony that these
are
separate from what the house the other
housing authorities request its specific
information yes i have never had that
request from any other housing authority
roughly 20 years i've been a landlord
as i'm reviewing these i i guess my
question is that these from my
perception these appear to be basic
safety standards that one might expect
in terms of being a property owner is
that accurate or
i agree with you there and we comply
with all of them
fully
and in fact when map boiler was replaced
we had the city of rochester in twice
inspecting the boiler during the
construction process to make sure we
complied with all codes
and i intend to comply with all codes my
issue is not so much that he's asking
for my issue is that he comes up with
his own rules out of nowhere
and i don't think that's fair to us that
we're getting different things from
different housing authorities
and different rules that the employees
make not even within i don't know if
this is even in hud i didn't have the
time to research it
thank you for taking my question thank
you for the question for the questions
for mr klein
thank you mr clyne
next we have
alyssa margolin
and you've asked for two minutes thank
you for being brief
members of the committee for the record
my name is alissa marglin i serve as
director of housing action new hampshire
we're a statewide coalition of 80
organizations
united around affordable housing policy
and ending homelessness in new hampshire
we are in support of house bill 1291 the
housing choice voucher program is a
really important tool in our work to
prevent homelessness and homelessness
and address our housing crisis in the
state
when
the the data that you received regarding
the usage rates of vouchers should be
a warning to all of us concerned about
housing stability in the state
we call it a success rate how many
voucher holders are
successful in using their voucher in the
private market
that success rate used to be in the 90s
not that long ago i would say five six
years ago
now we're hovering around sixty percent
of uh
of success for a voucher holder
to access a unit on the private market
as we've as you've heard again and again
below one percent vacancy rate there's
just not any market incentive for
landlords to take part in the program
the only way to really ensure that those
who need a voucher are able to use it in
the market is to pass a law like this
so
as you know we our our members are those
who develop manage affordable housing
as well as public housing authorities
and
supportive housing agencies and homeless
service agencies they are
dealing with
what the market
can't sustain on its own this is a very
important tool to them
and
and the passage of
house bill 1291 would be really an
important step forward to make this tool
viable again
thank you thank you thank you happy to
take care of you
questions
thank you very much
next up will be uh nick norman uh asking
for six to ten minutes i am sure that we
got uh a good background from uh mr
klein and uh if you could
consolidate see what i can do to keep it
brief thank you very much my name is
nick norman i am the apartment
associated in new hampshire government
affairs chair i lead the landlord
initiative on landlord-tenant law
you all know me quite well
um
so in a bill that's this large and has
so many extreme
uh bad consequences to both the real
estate market and to property owners
there's no way that i can
talk about all the bad points that are
here
but i did send out
a
email
a little bit ago late this morning so
that's in your inbox if you haven't
picked it up already
there's one
testimony here that i could pass around
it could be copied
so i'll cover as much as i can cover and
unfortunately don't have time to do the
rest
so the section 8 program was always and
still is designed by the federal
government to be a voluntary program
it needs to stay that way
the
using the program
costs extra money time and effort from a
property owner you've heard some of that
from
david klein
those costs are real
a lot of people don't know that there's
something called the rrp rule
the re repair renovate paint rule which
has to do with lead paint that rule has
two sides the epa side the hud side
when you have a section 8 tenant you're
forced into the hud side of the rule
the hud side of the rule has much more
restrictions costs and
requirements
than does the epa side
so immediately as soon as you have a
property built before 1978 which is
largely going to be the places that
you'll probably find
you know lower income lower rents
then
it's more expensive
just for that reason alone
we're very concerned as david klein said
that the bill does not make it clear
that you can use normal screening
methods to screen your tenants
that's going to make a landlord
hesitant to do the normal screening that
he would because it's not called out
that
they're going to
then not be held subject to a
discrimination lawsuit
the section 8 program comes with many
components contracts
lots of legalese
inspections
delays
another cost is the program
will typically always have some delay in
getting a tenant placed versus just the
open market on the open normal market i
can place a tenant within a day or two
in an apartment
with section 8 is probably going to be a
week or two at best because of all the
inspections and extra paperwork and
contracts and things that have to be
gone through so that's an extra expense
if you're forcing that on property
owners that's just another thing that's
going to happen that's going to have to
increase rents and worsen our housing
affordability
the thing we need to do
doesn't it make sense the thing we need
to do is to fix the program and provide
incentive incentives
so that property owners will want to use
the program the program used to be
better
decades ago than it is now
it used to be that you could
go into a section 8
tenancy and the housing authority would
guarantee you two months rent as a
security
that was taken away
now the tenant has to pay the security
deposit and it's only one month's rent
just as an example
there was a study that hud put out on
landlords experiences with the
choice voucher program
one of the key takeaways is that
property owners are largely frustrated
with the bureau
bureaucratic
inefficiencies and burdens of the
housing authority
landsale landlords also had more
negative experience with the voucher
holders
so
it's very clear if if you're a landlord
that the
it is very undesirable to have
the program it's not the tenants
it's not the source of income to say
that you're protecting against a source
of income that's ridiculous what does a
landlord care
where the money comes from
the problem is the program itself the
government bureaucracy the forcing of a
landlord into a government contract they
have no absolutely no say over
in the talking points that i've emailed
to you and in this one that was printed
out there's
two attachments i would encourage you to
look at those
one of them actually here you can pass
this around
that's one
page as a visual
this is
signing up a new tenant
on the regular open market
sorry i don't have big printers in ink
this
is the same process for section eight
probably at least three times as
complicated
time consuming
that's the handout that's being given to
you now
the
housing program has what's called the
a lease
and the
hap contract the housing authority
program contract
and that's 12 or 13 pages of legalese
that has all kinds of objectionable
clauses that you are forced to sign into
that
just restrict your property and you have
no say over
some of them say things like
the hud the
authority
will decide for their own sales if
you're allowed to sell the property to
your children
or family relatives
the the handout that i'm giving you is
in your email it just goes through point
by point this is incredible
i mean point after point page after pays
of a very objectionable contract details
i i guess i first
for time i won't go into all of them but
it's really
very objectionable
so
i feel like i'm at a loss when we come
to bills like this because there's so
much to say
this negative about it
i could go on for hours and i know we
can't do that
i don't know what to say
and i guess i'll stop there and
summarize that i please
would like you to read through
all the talking points that are there
it's a program that's
very objectionable
to landlords
it's not the source of the income it's
the strings that come with the program
and to have a law that forces a private
citizen into compliance with a
government contract that they have no
say over and dramatically affects their
income and business
i think should be unconstitutional and
illegal i don't know if it is but it
certainly should be
and i hope that you would vote in
expedient to legislate on this
i'm sure i haven't covered as much as i
need to
and i would be very willing to take
questions because there's a lot of mis
understanding about section 8.
thank you mr noman i appreciate you
keeping your comments
as tight as possible questions for mr
norman
thank you
representative langley
thank you mr chair and thank you mr
norman for taking my question
when you were giving your remarks you
made a comment about lead paid paint
abatement yes and how it was so much
more complex in terms of hot housing
do you know if there continues to be a
subsidy from hud
to help owners of property so that
they're able to facilitate that
abatement i am very aware of that and so
does it continue to exist
uh
yes
sort of but that's
it's not the full picture
to start off with what i was saying is
not related to abatement
so what i'm saying is when you're doing
a renovation
that's not an abatement
you are allowed to do that using rrp
rules
there's two sides to that rule with the
section 8 tenant you're forced into the
hud side of the rule which has more
regulation
so it's not about abatement at all
and there is
no
money
state or federal that i'm aware of that
will incentivize and provide owners
with the ability to do renovation
before a child is poisoned
abatement monies are after a child is
poisoned and now you're ordered to have
an abatement
and there are programs to assist with
that and they're very cumbersome and
many landlords have chosen not to even
use the
free money because it costs so much
to use it
thank you
claire and those programs do exist okay
follow up mr chair
um
again going back to the hud regulations
and the and the housing choice voucher
regulations
and talking about the complexity of
those regulations have you or your
organization made any effort to work
with new hampshire housing and finance
in terms of making some modifications to
those rules so that they're less
cumbersome for your industry
and what of the results of those
negotiations been if they've occurred
that's a really good question that's
where we need to be focusing our
attention is to fixing the program
there is a very large effort
with the national apartment association
talking directly with hud
hud doing studies
of the landlord community
and conversations that um
are ongoing
about
things that hud can or ought to be doing
to incentivize property owners to comply
and use the program so it's a pretty
concerted and prioritized as in a real
high priority of the national apartment
association
thank you yeah and what they found is
one thing for instance is the um that's
come from that is in new hampshire and i
think across the country
in many cases the housing authority is
providing a 1 000 payment to a property
owner as an incentive to take the
program
thank you
you might note that the program is so
onerous to the property owners they
still don't want to be involved
further questions for
representative simpson
thank you
and thank you for taking my question
thank you um
towards the end of your testimony you
mentioned that
land lords were being forced would be
forced by this bill to take these
tenants
and i'm i when i read the bill i don't
read it that way so i'm wondering if you
can
flesh that out
for me so when you have someone coming
to you to apply one of the things that a
landlord is always concerned about is am
i opening myself up to discrimination
lawsuit
just the accusation of a discrimination
lawsuit will probably cost you
minimum five thousand dollars even if
there was no discrimination at all
so
that's one thing
another is let's suppose you have a
tenant
that's already in your apartment they've
been there for five years
and now they've got themselves to the
top of the section eight list they're
now approved
now you're forced absolutely forced to
take that tenant onto section eight
because you've already got them in your
apartment they're already approved for
your apartment
and the way that the bill is written
it does not
exempt the normal criteria that
landlords use for screening so there's
going to be hesitancy on the
landlord
for denying people
based on their normal criteria
okay
any further questions thank you for the
question yeah
thank you mr norman
okay
i encourage people please call me
let's talk
next we have ellen
grow
and you've got two minutes and uh
appreciate you keeping
close to that if not tighter thank you
hi my name is ellen grow i'm the
executive director of the concord
coalition to end homelessness
we um
we provide some crisis services for
people who are homeless including a
daytime resource center an emergency
winter shelter and outreach program but
what we are really focused on is
permanent housing permanent supportive
housing for people leaving homelessness
and i'm talking in favor of this bill
the housing choice vouchers are one of
the subsidies that our clients rely on
to be able to afford the rent most of
the people we serve are
struggling to exist on
disability income around 800 a month so
even an apartment that's deemed
affordable they're not able to afford
that without a rental subsidy
you've heard a lot about how long these
wait lists are and they are but this
past summer there was a a wave of rent
of section 8 if you will through the
american rescue plan that was geared
specifically for people who are homeless
120 vouchers were issued and our clients
we were fortunate that 11 of our clients
we usually don't have any clients who
have a portable housing voucher in their
hands we had 11 people get vouchers and
to date only five of them have been able
to find a place to use that voucher two
of those were because our agency bought
a triplex that had two vacant units so
we were able to put two people in right
away but the rest are still homeless
they're still trying to find a place
that would accept that voucher
and we did offer an incentive as well
along with that and even that was not
enough to convince landlords to use this
program so i would not say that's a mark
of how onerous it is i think there are
landlords who
uh simply just say no the minute they
hear the word section 8 and maybe they
are just ignorant of the program or
maybe they have stereotypes of the
people who use the program but i think
this law would open the door to more
housing and to ending homelessness
this is the housing choice voucher is
one of the most important tools that we
have for ending homelessness but it is
worthless if people can't find a place
to use it
thank you and i had written testimony
but i realized i only copied one side of
it can i email that in later email will
be fine all right would you like the
physical copy
all right thank you thank you any uh
questions
miss grove
thank you very much thank you
next we would have
carol
lecote
if you repeat that when you get to the
microphone i'd appreciate it
it's pronounced lizat is that yes
um so i appreciate the opportunity to
just
speak on behalf of this bill i am in
support of
this bill
my role at
concord coalition to end homelessness is
an independent advocate
for clients
who are experiencing homelessness as
well as other
various disabilities
um and
i have had
years um in working with the homeless
population now about the past five years
i've worked in this area
so
in my time i've been able to develop
some relationships with landlords
um
in the past 30 months i mean 30 days
i have reached out to approximately 61
landlords
in concord area alone
and of those 61 landlords
21 of them
so about 35
of my total right now
have said
a hard no absolutely positively will not
work with anybody using any subsidy
whatsoever
i've also had the opportunity to discuss
with them
the landlord incentive program
that ellen mentioned
and
that is
just an additional
program
um and even with mention of that with
that extra support
it did not sway
uh any of these these landlords
so um
this bill would be
extremely helpful to our population
obviously it's not going to
affect
our
total numbers of homeless individuals uh
that much
but it will make a dent
um
and ultimately that's
i mean progress not perfection right so
we just want to make some progress with
this
issue that is affecting every single one
of us
because in the last five years our
numbers of homeless people on the
streets in concord alone have quadrupled
so
um
i am i'm hopeful that
we can support this bill um and work
towards making the adequate adjustments
to
the section 8 program as well moving
forward because
i i agree that the program is not ideal
and i know it's not perfect for the
landlords who are
dealing with it as it's not perfect for
the individuals who are being awarded it
but it is better than nothing
so
thank you for your testimony questions
for ms lazzotte
thank you very much thank you
uh for those coming it in for the two
o'clock hearing we are about a half hour
behind so bear with us we've got uh
three more speakers on this bill
the next being stephen
looks kind of like lewis
thank you and if you could be brief we
would appreciate it i understand we've
got a good picture of what's going on
here well
i am
i think it's important that you know
that not only am i an endangered species
because i'm a new hampshire native
i am a builder
and a
landlord
and i support the bill
when
i have been involved
in
multi-family housing management because
i build my own building so maybe that
makes life easier for me because i'm
building the building so they're always
to code
they always meet the inspections i
haven't had the problems these other
people have had
my working relationship with new
hampshire housing finance authority is
fairly good
but yes bureaucracy is bureaucracy
um but i think maybe my
visions of this is i
grew up poor i lived in a house no
central heat and no central plumbing so
i was one of those kind of people
and
i have not experienced problems with
tenants that have section 8 vouchers i
actually built one of the last section 8
project-based projects in hampstead new
hampshire
but again
it's important
that
the misconceptions that are out there
when i go to try to build a new project
i think people think that i don't do
credit checks that i don't do background
police checks there's nothing when i
look at this bill and i asked mr barry
about it and maybe we could sharpen the
language a little i don't believe that
this eliminates any of things that i
have to deny people
i've been working with section 8 since
how many years is that
44 years
and i have never been sued or
accosted for discrimination but i'm also
very careful in that
i just want
you know to know that
i've been a builder
i've been a
a tenant and i do property management
and i think that we we do have a serious
crisis on on housing i do agree with a
lot of stuff there really needs to be
some more support it would be much
easier for my fellow
landlords to get some
support when they have a problem with a
tenant and they don't right now
but in general my experience has not
been a negative with this program and
you need to know that
and i cut my speech in half thank you mr
lewis for the brief testimony uh
questions for mr lewis
thank you very much
next we have brie whalen
for two minutes
thank you
hi everyone thanks for having me um my
name is bree whalen and i'm one of those
mystery 15 1800 uh voucher holders
i am an artist
i
have been sober for six years
i have multiple sclerosis
and i have a low income
i have no evictions and no criminal
record
i am sitting here as we speak
as a homeless resident in the state
for over a year
and that was after being in an abusive
relationship in order to keep a roof
over my head
because walking the streets of
manchester with ms is really hard
and no matter what i do
without a bill like this
i am not this person i'm here to show
you who we are we are people with real
lives
that just want the chance
to have stability and safety
out of every hundred apartments i look
at online
there might be
40 that are even close to affordable
out of those 40.
at least 25 directly list section 8 not
welcome
i have a 2 bedroom section 8 voucher
and i also have 18 up to 18 months of
emergency rental assistance through
and
excuse me
southern new hampshire services there we
go
um and i'm begging
for a home with no evictions and no
criminal oh and i have landlord
references i have neighbor references
i'm friends with them all still i'm a
good tenant i'm quiet i'm sober i'm kind
i'm an advocate in the community
i'm an artist i like to leave things
beautiful
one of the things that i'd like to say
is i'm an artist right i paint big
beautiful pictures that everybody loves
usually the comment is holy
yikes we'll say yikes is the word
um
and it actually came from brain damage
from ms i'm a savant artist out of
nowhere
and i go around the community and i
paint live for people
and i do the whole bob ross thing and
it's therapeutic for them and me
um
i work with other homeless people to try
to help them i go back with pots of soup
literally like
it is so difficult out there
and
i don't even have a chance
i i i'm not i am not a face or a person
when it comes to these applications
because the second they hear section 8
or a voucher or anything i become
something else
and that's it and there's no chance for
me to be who i am here's what i wanted
to say right so i'm an artist i have
this big sunset painting and i
can't mix this color that i need to
finish it i've been working on it for
two years
and i can't mix this color and i'm not a
trained artist right so this is a
difficult thing i have
but you know what i don't do i don't
complain about that to people because
that's my job my job today is to finish
that painting
so when i hear things about paperwork
and
i don't know inspections and things like
that i feel like if this is the business
you chose
then that's part of your job you guys
are all sitting here with pens and
papers in hand i see you taking notes
looks i bet you have a lot of paperwork
in your life
that is not my job thank god
i could barely fill out the sign in card
you know what i mean but i didn't choose
anything that had that today because
that's not something i want to deal with
if that's your occupation
so be it
how is that my fault
why do i not get a chance at safe fair
housing
being a good person i'm a good person
but on paper
i'm a castaway because of of this and
it's getting worse
the other day i saw the very first
you asked for two minutes i think we
have your idea
i just wanted to say the other day i
actually saw rentals starting the list
that say no vouchers accepted not even
just section 8. it's getting worse we
need something please
and
please hope that i get housing
thank you any questions
thank
you our last that i have a card for is
um
yes i need my glasses of course i do
lindsey lee lincoln
for two minutes and you support the bill
yes i support the bill um thank you
lindsay lincoln i'm an attorney with new
hampshire legal assistance
um i just wanted to respond to a couple
of points raised um by those in
opposition to the bill and hopefully
offer some clarification
um one was the mention um that
rents change in the middle of a lease
term
um and i think there are letters
included in one of those packets that um
were used to support that point but i
just want to make clear that the
contract rent for a section 8 voucher
holder does not change during a lease
term
the housing authority
does not unilaterally
change the amount of contract rent that
is that is owed to the landlord a
tenant's income may change during the
duration of the lease and because under
the program
they by and large pay 30
of their income on rent if their income
changes
the housing assistance payment may
increase or decrease based on that
change in income of the tenant so it is
that that is changing the the portion of
the payment that is covered by the
tenant the portion of the payment that
is covered by the housing authority but
the overall contract rent paid to the
landlord does not change during the
lease term
let's see oh another point
was that
entering into a
contract with a voucher holder would
limit the ability of landlords to evict
for
things such as police calls to the unit
or certain behaviors that would
otherwise violate lease terms
that that is not true
under
rsa 540 landlords can evict for cause
that includes things like violation
material violations of lease terms
threats to health and safety of
landlord staff or other residents so
the ability to evict for cause is no
different for a voucher holder tenant
than a tenant who is unsubsidized
oh finally i would just like to say that
there is um the bill explicitly says
that
it would be it's prohibited to refuse to
rent to someone on the basis that they
are participant in the housing choice
voucher program that is the limiting
language on the basis of or because of
um and so it is similar to the other
provisions in rsa 354a that prohibit
discrimination based on other protected
classes it does not prohibit a landlord
from applying normal screening
procedures it merely prohibits the
exclusive denial
denial based exclusively on the person
having a voucher a housing choice
voucher
um and i would just say i think
several other concerns
um are addressed from the two
exceptions in this bill either that the
market rate is above what the
payment standard is for the housing
authority or that the housing itself
doesn't meet housing quality standards
thank you attorney lincoln any questions
for attorney
lincoln thank you very much thank you
and uh anyone
else want to speak on hb
i will close the hearing on hb 1291
and we will go next
to
house bill
1315.
and welcome
representative mooney
thank you
we are
um
like
welcome representative mooney you can
proceed thank you very much
well thank you mr chairman and members
of the committee i appreciate your time
and attention for the record my name is
state representative maureen mooney i
represent the town of merrimack that's
hillsborough county district number 21.
i have some testimony that's being
distributed though i will say what i'm
my remarks verbally to you are going to
be different than what my handout is so
just be aware of that
i am the prime sponsor of house bill
because the law of new hampshire needs
to be changed to provide a degree of
legal protection to sports officials who
contribute their time energy and
experience each year on behalf of the
citizenry and youth of our wonderful
state
house bill 1315
gives sports officials immunity from
civil liability for negligent acts or
emissions
providing the official
a
was scheduled to officiate the game
b acted in good faith and within the
scope of functions and duties
and c did not exercise a willful act or
gross
negligence
currently the law limits simple
negligence liability for the benefit of
only volunteers
the intent of house bill 1315 is to
expand the protection to include sports
officials who receive a minor stipend or
reimbursement for expenses for
officiating school athletes and
non-profit sporting contests and events
throughout new hampshire
house bill 1315 is designed to provide
legal protection from being sued
for negligence to men and women who give
their time to officiate sports for the
betterment of our state's youth each
year
this is an important basis for changing
the current law
please understand that sports officials
are not responsible for sponsoring
hosting controlling the public coaching
managing the school or game
administration nor do they have any
personal control over the participants
other than the authority that a sports
official possesses to officiate the
specific sporting event itself
recall all event related functions are
principally the school or sponsoring
entities responsibility and attendant
liability
sports participant conduct participation
and equipment as well as the conduct of
the team and staff are largely overseen
by the head coach school administration
athletic association or club in
conjunction with the local sponsor or
school administrator for
that specific activity
officials don't manage those things it
is important to understand that the
sports officials are directed to appear
to perform a limited function at a
sporting event and after it is over they
then leave as their responsibilities
have been completed
remember that sports officials are
required to be neutral
independent and unbiased during the
athletic event they are officiating
in doing so sports officials basically
perform the role of judges within that
sporting event
however unlike state judges who enjoy
complete legal immunity in the discharge
of their public duties
sports officials
currently are legally subject to
personal liability and being sued for
blowing their whistles or not blowing
their whistles throwing a flag or not
throwing a flag making a call or even
exercising their judgment not to do so
since tv commentating and instant replay
have become so predominant in the
broadcasting of sports throughout our
country technology has made officiating
even harder with people constantly
second guessing what sports officials do
or don't do
even at the state level
what has happened is that during the
past decades sports officials across the
country have become targets of
negligence lawsuits which should have no
place in our courts
the
nhiaa standing for new hampshire
inter-scholastic athletic association
coordinates athletic competition
and programs for high schools throughout
the state
the
nhiaa works and coordinates with each of
the recognized new hampshire school
sports official groups
each sport is regulated by a governing
body which specifically organizes trains
and then certifies qualified men and
women to officiate sporting events in
that discipline throughout each year
in the past the first nhiaa
executive director submitted testimony
encouraging the committee to pass this
bill due to the problems that he
personally encountered because such
litigation has already created a climate
of fear and intimidation towards new
hampshire sports officials
while it may be pointed out that by
enacting the bill sports officials will
become a protected class
that from time to time happens in the
law as laws have been enacted to protect
various businesses involved in sports
activities
for example
ski operators who are protected from
negligence liability
are so under rsa 225
hyphen a colon 24.
in summary please now vote in favor of
house bill 1315
in an effort to help protect our
sporting officials and to recruit more
for years down the line as i know we're
all very cognizant of how very important
sports are to the youth of new hampshire
with that i'll conclude my remarks and i
thank those who are here for listening
and for your attention during my
testimony thank you
thank you representative moody any
questions for representative mooning
seeing none we thank you for your
testimony thank you and i see a sign
here wipe microphones down after each
use so i'll take a moment to all right
follow that
very explicit instruction very good
thank you mr chairman you apparently are
the second one to read that sign
next would be
marissa chase
speaking against the bill
safe one for me
welcome ms chase
thank you representatives um good
afternoon thank you for the opportunity
to testify before you my name is marissa
chase i'm the executive director of the
new hampshire association for justice
which is a statewide association of
attorneys
mostly representing the interests of
plaintiffs in our state
we are opposed to this bill because
immunities are a dog whistle
in our organization
immunity is giving any actor who's
defined carte blanche to act without
responsibility
responsibility as a negligence
negligence is a high bar to meet
to bring a negligence claim you have to
prove that the person you are you know
suing civilly
acted in a way that a reasonable person
would not under the same or similar
circumstances
it is a bridge too far
to grant this to paid sports officials
we view this through a lens of safety
and responsibility any bill that again
grants brought immunity to any defined
actor waves that actors responsibility
sports officials have a duty of care to
ensure that children are operating in a
safe environment using safe equipment
earlier in another hearing we talked
about ministerial and discretionary
duties
what if a soccer coach sees a child get
hit in the head but fails to stop the
game so the proper pro concussion
protocols can happen
the child then collapses with a serious
head injury which could have been
minimized had the game been stopped
earlier what about any sort of shooting
sport where a referee clearly sees
someone not handling their weapon
properly shouldn't they have a duty to
either take them out of the contest or
correct the dangerous situation before
another contestant is injured
we understand that referees can't be
responsible for the normal injuries
faced during sports sprained ankles
injuries etc nor do we expect them to
control the crowd of you know
impassioned onlookers
but they do make a lot of critical calls
that if left without the responsibility
to do so could lead to unnecessary risk
and injury
again it's very hard to bring a civil
claim in new hampshire especially i
i can't see the examples i can't think
of the examples that representative the
prime sponsor
spoke of earlier
but truly the only the only immunity you
need is to act responsibly as a
reasonable person would under the
circumstances
i'd also like to point out that our
state
um does not our courts do not recognize
gross negligence
our courts have never interpreted that
we don't recognize degrees of negligence
in this state in the civil context
and i would also say
the bill is very overly broad it does
not define good faith
so we respectfully urge you to vote in
expedient to legislate
thank you miss chase any questions
representative walper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
i
have a hard time with the idea that
officials are responsible for the
equipment that
like hockey player or football player or
anybody might actually be using i'm
having a very difficult time thinking
about how they could be
charged with some kind of negligence
that could say lead to an injury that
would really do awesome
i am too
oh well thank you
guess that qualifies us a question um
further questions
thank you miss chase thank you
and next up is uh
brian snow
and this is the last pink card that we
have for this uh bill if anyone else
wants to testify
you can prepare your pink's
pink card
now
welcome
uh if you could press the microphone
button start that
good afternoon members of the community
perfect i don't mean to block your view
so i'll kind of sit kitty corner if i
could
um i'm here obviously in support of
house bill 1315
i'm a practicing attorney i've been for
42 plus years i also am a sports
official i've had an opportunity to
officiate
middle school basketball baseball
i've been high school football officials
since 2000
and a college ncaa football official
since 2017.
and sadly
we have um a problem with liability
what you have in front of you is a
letter from patrick corbin
he was our first
executive director of the nhia and he
himself
was sued
for being an official
he was a soccer official
up in lebanon and hanover
and as a part of
one of the games that he officiated up
there because it's kind of a rivalry so
he told me
was that
things got out of hand
some kids
injured each other and so
their lawyers sued everybody the school
system school administration
the coaches
and himself
and the case itself
took years and wound up in the new
hampshire supreme court
he had absolutely nothing to do with it
and yet he had to pay time and attention
to that
unfairly
as chief justice roberts of the u.s
supreme court once said
um judges
in an analogy to sports officials are
like
um
umpires
they call balls and strikes they don't
pitch
and they don't catch
their role is very limited
in new hampshire we have recognized
some of the difficulties that sports
officials have
by creating a community for volunteer
high school and
youth
coaches as well as officials they have
to be volunteers
the issue has become more difficult
for officials because
now people are more
upset i'll say with game situations
perhaps if you all caught the 49ers
and
dallas cowboy game last weekend
um there was a tough officiating call at
the end of the game
the dallas cowboys ran a play
and then
ran out of time
what was the reaction the reaction folks
if you didn't happen to catch it was
that the
texans that were there and other
citizens
aimed garbage and things at the
officials because they didn't like the
call
that was unfortunate
it was unfortunately things like that
have grown
uh a number of states now have
harassment legislation and things like
that
but it's easy when you're doing
um
wide scale litigation to include anybody
and everybody that was there
and we're trying to carve out
a protection for sports officials you
say well
why ryan well because of the liability
because the compensation for doing high
school games is less than a hundred
dollars
in football or baseball or basketball or
things like that
why buy a two-year
multi-thousand dollar case litigation
just because you've got a hundred
dollars to do the game and get caught up
into that
it's not fair
as i said
the people that run the program um the
owners much like on landlord liability
um are limited because they're a
non-profit
or governmental entity but not the
officials
um it was previously pointed out that
that
that wanton and gross negligence
isn't a part of new hampshire law well i
would commend you to read some of the
exceptions that are put in rsa 508
for example for the fire responders
for law enforcement
for a landlord
for
the good samaritans it also uses the
language
gross negligence
and intentional torts
it's there
so i would commend you when you hear
that that's not the case
it isn't part it is part of new
hampshire law it's specifically printed
there
uh
as far as the comments that there's a
duty of
uh to inspect the equipment that's not
so
in fact what happens is the officials
when we start out we ask the coaches to
make a representation
in high school orally and in college in
writing that they're properly equipped
we can't second guess
a hundred people on each side um
kids and and uh
collegians
uh whether they're properly equipped
we're not
required nor responsible for whether
they are properly equipped it's the
coaching it's the school
same type of thing with head injuries
if we recognize it but recall these are
citizens that aren't doctors or emts
and they do the best they can but you
can't catch everything that happens on
the field there's only seven of us
in college and only five of us in high
school on the football field at a given
time
and you're talking 22 kids
out there
so
the requirement
is that it was just mentioned previously
that we're responsible for that for
identifying that
is
difficult
it's easy to miss it especially if you
ask the
participant are you okay and he says
yeah
and i've had that happen to me many
times
and i've had to order them off the field
on occasion if i feel that that's not
true but i'm not an emt
i just have to use my my my judgment in
that reaction but that doesn't mean that
it's that the kid doesn't have a problem
but it's the coach's responsibility
to monitor that behavior not the
officials
in the first instance
um and the same thing with shooting
sports that's done by a
institution be it the school if it's
sponsoring it or
whatever the club is
it's
not the firearms
official
to be responsible for those type of
actions
in those instances and in fact there's
an exception in the law unlimited
liability for
firearms in that situation too
as you'll see in 508. is there any
questions that i can answer
questions for attorney snow
well thank you for you have covered
everything thank you very much
any further testimony on hb-13
thank you
i just wanted to um
say that yes gross negligence is written
in our statutes i stated our courts have
not interpreted what gross negligence
means our courts have not interpreted
degrees of negligence in the civil
setting that's not to say they're not on
the books the other thing i didn't
mention a duty of equipment but a duty
of care and a duty of care is essential
in a negligence claim to determine who's
responsible that's all i wanted to
clarify
thank you any questions for miss chase
thank you very much thank you
without further testimony we will close
the hearing on hb1315
and
return the chair
to its proper
owner
are you back
oh
the committee will be in recess until
quarter of three
um
is
chances
we're back
she'll fix everything i'm broke
well i supposed
uh
okay
business
now
thank you
um
chief
thank you
yes
i know
oh
yep
three
action
okay
we'll call the house judiciary committee
back to order
our next item of business is a hearing
on house bill 1425 relative to the
taking of real property by eminent
domain
and i will call upon the prime sponsor
representative melissa bleisick
mr chairman members of the committee yes
i'm melissa blasik and i represent
hillsborough 21 the town of merrimack
and i'm here to introduce hb 1425 fn
this bill seeks to amend rsa 446
the state of emergency statutes are rsa
4 45 through 4 447
rsa 446 grants the executive branch the
ability to seize private property during
a state of emergency
it was not used at all during the
covid19 state of emergency and i don't
believe it has ever been implemented
however no one knows what the future
holds and while many of us agree that
emergency authority must exist for
extraordinary circumstances that
authority should still be tailored to
prevent potential abuse of power
people's natural rights do not cease to
exist during an emergency and those
rights must remain protected
to quote james madison an elective
despotism was not the government we
fought for but one in which the powers
of government should be so divided and
balanced among the several bodies of
majesty is that no one could transcend
their legal limits without being
effectually checked and restrained by
the others
state of emergency powers hand an
enormous amount of authority to the
executive branch and i believe it is our
duty to restrain this authority as much
as possible while still allowing the
executive branch to handle any emergency
that may arise
this bill makes several changes to the
existing statute it adds language that
there must be a documented inability to
obtain alternative resources before
taking private property
it adds more compensation for the taking
of the property and it ensures that once
the state no longer needs the property
that the owner has the right of first
refusal to purchase it back at
prevailing market price
this bill justly places the entire cost
burden associated with eminent domain
during a state of emergency in the hands
of the state where it belongs
that concludes my testimony i'd be happy
to take questions
questions from committee
i have a stack here
that i thought had been handed out but
i'm not sure
i will look for it
it's gone missing
no that's not it i put it right there
okay did we find it yes okay
oh
representative langley thank you mr
chair i'm sorry i was slow on this one
can you can you clarify for me um
under when documented when there's a
documented inability to obtain
alternative resources
so is that
if you if the state was going to
take property i mean how is that work
would it it would it be if i had money
that was so
valuable as it currently as the law
currently stands
um
the burden is not on the state to show
that they have no resources of their own
to
take someone else's property so this is
just that it has to be documented in
writing that the state doesn't have any
other resources available to them
thank you
any other questions
thank you representative
is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on house bill 12 1425
seeing none we will close the hearing on
house bill 1425.
and we'll just be in recess till three
o'clock when we have our next hearing
okay we'll call the house judiciary
committee back to order
our next item of business is a hearing
on house bill
1544.
that's prohibiting the placement of
construction and demolition debris in
landfills and we'll call upon the
sponsor of that bill representative mick
williams to introduce the bill and
provide her testimony
thank you very much mr chair and members
of the committee it's a pleasure to be
here for the record my name is
representative rebecca mcwilliams i
represent the west side of concord and
you are currently sitting in my district
so i'm pleased to host you
in concord
i'm just going to give you a little bit
of background on this bill because i was
thinking you know how much does
judiciary really know about waste and
recycling and construction and
demolition debris so let me just give
you a little bit of history
in 2019
the house
convened a commission to look at
recycling and debris and understand
what's going on with our landfills and
what we're accepting in terms of waste
in new hampshire
so there were a series of
recommendations that came out of that
commission
and one of those is currently a task
force that's looking at ways that we can
effectively reduce waste in landfills
and of course one of those big issues
that we've been talking about
since 2019
is what's going on with construction and
demolition debris specifically so to set
the table for you
you kind of need to understand what's
happening in the states surrounding new
hampshire
so just historically i've given you the
first i believe the first five pages
of new hampshire's 2019 biennial solid
waste report it's got a
beautiful new hampshire department of
environmental services logo on the
bottom of that report
i didn't print the whole thing because i
think the most important thing to look
at
is what's been going on
and let me find the quote
on officially page one at the bottom the
introduction
so in 1990 we're looking at paragraph
two
rsa 149m was amended to establish a a
waste reduction goal
a current version of the school
established in 1999
was to divert 40 percent of new
hampshire's solid waste from final
disposal by the year 2000
in order to reduce the quantity of solid
waste
so that's something that we've been
working on
since 1990 is to continually reduce
solid waste in our landfills
interesting to note
that
the way that our department of
environmental services addresses waste
is through what's called a waste
hierarchy
so looking at the bottom of page one
the very last thing you want to be doing
with waste is putting it in a landfill
right that's at the very bottom of the
pyramid
the most preferred is source reduction
so let's get rid of things that we
shouldn't be throwing away anyway often
in practice that looks like changing
over from
disposable containers to reusable
containers you'll often see that you can
purchase at some stores liquid detergent
in your own container rather than
purchasing detergent in a plastic
container that would be source reduction
the next is recycling and reuse and so
once again i'm setting the table here
in the last five years we've seen a huge
increase in recycling and reuse of
construction materials in our
neighboring states
so
i provided a little bit of background
information from the
sisters to the new hampshire department
of environmental services we have
in massachusetts
it's
make sure i get this right
in massachusetts is the department of
environmental protection
in maine
it's the dep i believe that's also
environmental protection and then in
vermont it's the department of
environmental conservation
so in these three states in the last
five years what they've started to do
is to track and divert
construction and demolition debris when
it comes to a facility to be processed
i think that's really important that
they've set goals for how much they will
accept
and in both vermont and maine they've
created facilities that are specific to
construction and demolition debris so
let's just say your general contractor
you're tearing down an old house
you need to bring all the waste that
ends up in your dumpsters to a c d
facility if you're working in maine and
vermont
or
you can bring it to new hampshire
and so what we're seeing statistically
data wise in the last five years is the
amount of waste that we are receiving
from out of state has gone up
approximately 50
and i'm not saying that it's all
construction and demolition debris but
there seems to be perhaps some kind of a
correlation between massachusetts who
has the strictest rules we'll talk about
them in a minute
maine and vermont who've set up their
own c d facilities and are requiring
recycling
and new hampshire not actually having
rules on the books right now to address
that so there may be something about
that influx of waste coming from out of
state
but
um it's also coming from in-state right
we're in the midst of a huge
construction boom and we have limited
sites on which to build new houses so
often what you're seeing is these old
1920s 1940s cottages are being torn down
the waste has to go somewhere
and then a new home is built on the same
lot
so we're not innocent of sending waste
to our facilities that is the c d type
so the intention with creating this bill
and i know it's a really simple bill
it's just one single line saying
prohibiting any landfill permitted by
the department that would be des from
accepting construction and demolition
debris
and then setting a fine for anyone who
actually does it
the intention here is to set up just
like we've seen
in maine and
in vermont
a facility that can receive construction
and demolition debris
and not send it to the very bottom of
this pyramid here land filling
they can come up with alternative and
additional uses for things like
clean drywall or recycling dirty drywall
studs
um
asphalt shingles all of these can find a
better purpose than ending up in our
landfills
so
i promised i'd get to massachusetts this
is probably the strictest and the most
complicated one but it's worth talking
about
so what massachusetts has done is
they've created
a construction and demolition handling
facility criteria
and i think that that's worth looking at
because they've set a percentage goal
for process separation
for facilities that are receiving
construction demolition debris and
making sure that they're split out into
different piles of things
often this means that you're requiring
the contractor to separate it on site so
when it arrives at the facility you're
not doing the the dump of all the stuff
on the concrete pad and having to go
through it to pull out studs versus
drywall versus bat insulation
it's all separated already by the time
it gets to the facility
so the goal in massachusetts is to
achieve right now as of october 2021 so
we're still under the current
requirements in mass
the goal is to achieve a process
separation rate minimum threshold of 15
percent
and then demonstrate that the waistband
materials are separated so wasteband
materials would include things like
drywall studs asphalt shingles
to the greatest extent possible where
all human mistakes happen
it's not possible to be perfect when
you're handling waste
so
you don't fail you don't get kicked out
of the program there's just sort of a
retraining process if you're not able to
achieve that 15
minimum threshold but i think that
that's something worth looking at as
well in new hampshire where right now
when we receive waste at a facility it
may or may not be already separated by a
contractor there may not be an
opportunity to separate it when it's
already tipped on the floor
so we're just looking at as i said
neighboring states what their policies
are with c d waste what we can do better
here in new hampshire
and i believe that this is probably the
lowest hanging fruit for us to change
our regulations to make it easier for
people to separate out before it gets to
a facility push that back on the
contractors who are already doing it in
new hampshire maine vermont i'm sorry
doing it at main vermont and
massachusetts and many of these
contractors are working in multiple
states
so we would be looking to do more of a
uniform requirement they separate out
the waste before it comes here
so i'm not saying that the wording of my
bill is exactly what i'd like it to be
but i think there's a conversation to be
had here so with that i'm happy to take
some questions
questions
for representative williams
yes representative simpson
thank you
and thank you representative for taking
my question um i just wanted to clarify
the 15
is
like the contractors trying to get down
to that amount that smaller amount that
would have to be processed at the
facility
that would have to be separated rather
at the facility like separating the
other 85 percent at the site i'm sorry i
didn't understand what the 15 was so the
goal is that the facility
needs to hit a 15 separation rate it's a
low first step first threshold to only
get to 15.
it will probably go up again in a couple
of years to something like 20 percent
and then 25
in a couple more years the goal is to be
training people who are doing this type
of work and demolishing buildings
bringing it to a facility that they need
to separate it out more and more and
more and it becomes more normal so 15 is
just the threshold first step small
amount for separation at the facility
representative silvia
so if
contractors are going to be separating
this stuff out that means more work for
them uh we've already got a monstrous
housing crunch
um
is this going to cost
you know is going to rise raise
the cost of housing in the state
that's an interesting conundrum for the
trade-off right so what we're talking
about is an upfront cost
for demolition as part of construction
or just demolition as part of a project
you may just be demoing and having land
afterwards
there's a cost to that
and then there's the cost to the state
to be land filling long-term materials
that don't necessarily need to be
landfilled right so there's a value a
cost that you could associate with with
a cleanup
later on
or with just having to increase
footprint of landfill now right there
these are two costs that have to be
balanced
i don't have any studies actually
weighing what the cost is
for measuring and separating out
demolition debris for new hampshire
projects i think that would be a good
number to get
but i would say that just looking at it
from a big picture we can't continue on
the same road we've been going on which
is accepting construction and demolition
debris from all our neighbors whoever
wants to bring anything will take it and
in a lot of cases it ends up in a
landfill right that's not sustainable we
can't keep doing that for the long term
or we'll run out of space
other questions for representative
mcwilliams
seeing them thank you
oh sorry representative walper
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
so i'm slightly confounded here so when
you say the 15
and separation
it sounds like all you're talking about
sounds to me that uh is that like the
two by fours and nails going to one pile
and the sheetrock goes in another pile
and i take the same amount of stuff to
the landfill
so what am i missing here i'm sorry
there's recycling right after the
separation
so it's separated and then it's recycled
so so the
okay so the 15
you're saying that that
that the facility
will
um
recycle 15 percent more will vary 15
percent less
which way are we looking at that
so they have to separate out that 15 to
head to recycling
and it really depends on how it's being
recycled right so you can
you can take asphalt shingles and grind
them down and they can be used for road
work just as an example that's 100
recycling of whatever 15
or less than 15 of the shingles you've
salvaged of your overall
incoming trash right
so the same thing with studs
wood studs if you've got them as a
percentage of your 15 percent
you're going to find another use for
them
i don't believe in new hampshire we're
allowed to burn them
but often they end up getting buried so
they become back to the earth material
again
so
so the process that that you're
promoting here is that the contractors
sort out the materials
take them to the landfill
or to the the transfer transfer stations
yeah i have a hard time with that in my
town as well
right take them to the transfer station
and then transfer station
distributes them to be recycled that's
right the fifteen percent happens at the
transfer station and the fifteen percent
is fifteen percent of what the facility
takes in of that type of debris correct
that's the massachusetts standard okay i
get that
another one
okay now how about the costs the cost of
it's easy to envision the cost of
sorting and
transporting or whatever that's going to
be increased on the contractor side of
it
the cost
of the re to the transfer station and or
to the which is only part of the cost of
the state i think
from
that perspective but
is there
is this a is this a cost item or a
profit item for the transfer stations
you know what we're seeing in other
states
is that it tends to be a wash
but there are people here who will
testify after me and give you real life
stories i'm not in the industry so i
can't tell you that every time you make
up with recouping the sale versus the
labor required to send it off site to
recycle i can't tell you that for sure
i'm not in a position to make that
assurance
but i can tell you that it seems to be
worth it for these other states because
they are able to recoup some money
that's it thank you
can you talk 15 of you talking volume or
weight
oh no good question
that's an excellent question i'm going
to go back to this the sheet because i
don't have that at the tip of my fingers
let's look at massachusetts
there it is
i'm going to have to get back to you on
whether it's weight or volume for the 15
i know they measure both right they're
weighing the trucks and they're also
saying that that looks like it appears
to be a five yard dumpster or whatever
they're bringing in
so i'll get back to you on that one
thank you
any other questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
today thank you very much
next person who submitted a card is bob
magnussen
good afternoon chairman i'm going to
take my mask off here
members of the committee my name is bob
magnuson i
have worked for 26 years for waste
management
waste management is
heavily involved in the collection and
transportation and disposal
of c d materials in new hampshire
through our network of collection
operations we run one out of rochester
out of londonderry new hampton and keene
we have we have a couple of transfer
stations
where
small vehicles come in with materials
and then they they leave from there in
larger vehicles
we have a transfer station in auburn and
then one that we operate the city of
laconia's facility and we have the
landfill over in rochester where we
receive a variety of of materials
so house bill 1544 an act prohibiting
the placement of construction and
demolition debris in landfills
while waste management we support
various recycling initiatives
across the board whether it's municipal
solid waste think of the paper and
cardboard and things you might generate
at your home as well as
construction and demolition on the
commercial side we do
oppose this bill as it's as it's drafted
i feel this is quite a jump to go from
where we're at to the f
you know potential fines and penalties
that are outlined in this so in my
testimony that i've provided the written
testimony
i did just pull out of the rsa what the
definition of c and d is it's always
good to kind of refresh what we're
talking about
c d is generated by most residents
businesses and institutions in the state
on a on a very routine basis
through any sort of construction
projects that might take place either at
their home or their place their place of
work
and the definition
that we're working from i
again i put in the testimony
how much c d are we talking about
now new hampshire doesn't generate as
much c d as municipal solid waste what
we generate in our home in our business
or what's classified as municipal solid
waste
but the quantity is significant
it's often
related to economic activities and some
type of construction is involved
we did a review of the annual facility
reports those are reports that solid
waste facilities in new hampshire submit
every year to des
a little outdated so i think the numbers
would be
in line with this but possibly higher we
took a review of the
2018 annual facility reports
we did that review back in 19
and that indicated there was
new hampshire generated over 425 000
tons of c d
with about a hundred and seventy seven
thousand seven hundred tons
sent to the two primarily primary
privately owned c and d processing
facilities which are located down in the
southern tier of the state they're not
waste management facilities
they are facilities that we work
closely with as our trucks will go into
those facilities and some of the
products that they generate in their
processing operation
do require outlet at a landfill because
there are not other
viable outlets for those materials
so there's a remaining 247 000 plus tons
of unprocessed cnd
that went to
based on our review went to in-state and
out-of-state landfills for disposal
and it is important to note that c d
processing facilities
do not recycle 100
of what they receive
and landfills are often an important
outlet for several of the products
that are generated by c d processing
processing facilities
some of those materials that a c d
processing facility might generate that
would end up in a landfill
they'll often screen out materials that
they don't have other outlets for
sometimes they're called fines sometimes
they're called screenings they can be
used at landfills
to cover the waste at the end of the day
so
it's a higher use than just
disposing of the unprocessed c and d but
nonetheless it is going to a landfill
and in review of this language of this
bill
i take it to mean
any c d product couldn't go to a
landfill which is which is
quite encompassing
some other materials that c d processing
facilities generate
that might go to a landfill as there are
wood products they'll often pull out the
clean wood
for wood fuels and other sort of wood
products think of plywoods and press
boards and things like that
but there are other
materials that they generate that
don't otherwise have a home
so as far as our first major opposition
to this bill
is the fact that there currently do not
exist in new hampshire processing
facilities capable of taking on this
quantity of material
and the small transfer stations that
might take in some of this material and
transfer it for disposal now
i don't believe that they have the
physical space to set up this separation
and
it was alluded to
by the sponsor of the bill about setting
cans and containers up at construction
facilities and that is a great
in my opinion the best way to get to it
but you got to get the build you got to
get the contractors in here and have
that dialogue because
the
setting up multiple containers for
materials before they get mixed in with
the weights is a great way of doing it
but there are often constraints on
construction sites
you know what might be handled now in
one container we might be talking about
three four five containers additional
transportation costs
to to pick up each of those containers
separately and send them somewhere
but that is a good way to to get to
you know to get to this
so we feel that there aren't
facilities out there that are capable of
of handling this
you do have a couple of great there are
a couple of great operators in the state
and
i know there have been others that have
pursued
c d processing facilities in other parts
of the state
and their solid waste facility and they
run into certain amount number of
challenges to get those permitted and
some have been unsuccessful in that so
to jump from
right to
a prohibition
i feel is is is is premature that that's
that's uh
that's uh uh
you feel it's gonna result in a lot of
extra cost in the industry and
physically i'm not sure that it's it's
really not physically even required i
mean viable
and as i mentioned
existing landfills do provide a
necessary outlet for these c d
processing facilities
so
whether it's one of those other products
i described
there's still going to be
certain products from facilities that
recycle c d that are going to need an
outlet a locally available
landfill outlet in my opinion
and third the proposed penalties are
really
very very high for
you know the relative type of penalty
we're talking about the 20 250 to 2500
25 000
um you know their our industry would
likely set up a way that we would
inspect those materials and then pass
that back to
whoever brought that into
our facility and that could be
anybody from a large contractor to a
small local contractor that brings in
the material we you know quote unquote
catch them
assess fines i mean i think that's a
that's uh there are other ways to kind
of get there and i think that solid
waste committee that's been
put together
this is something that i believe they're
taking a look at is how do we move the
needle on on c and d processing as well
as other materials
and um jumping right to this like a
penalty based
prohibition we feel is uh inappropriate
at this time so
uh thank you for the opportunity to
testify and if you have any questions
for me
questions
i see none thank you for your testimony
today thank you
michael nork
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
my name is michael nork i represent the
solid waste management bureau at the new
hampshire department of environmental
services
the department opposes hb 1544
and mr magnussen
basically summarized a lot of the
similar concerns that we have
let me just back up for a second and
explain that in new hampshire
generators of c d waste generally have
two options
they have the option of putting c d in a
landfill
directly
they have the option of putting c d
through a processing facility as
representative mcwilliams alluded to and
also mr magnuson alluded to these
facilities that process cnd
essentially
recover and recycle what they can and
the rest of it goes to a landfill so
even if cnd were to go to a processing
facility there's still a need for
disposal of
whatever remnants or residuals
that they can't recover
and to be clear what hp 1544 would do
would essentially create a zero
tolerance policy
for
c d going to a landfill
this we see as a potential problem
because as mr magnuson alluded to
there isn't an extensive network of cnd
processing facilities throughout the
state currently there are a few a
handful
and they do process a fair amount of c
and d waste from new hampshire
generators as well as from other states
uh the problem is that even if we were
to institute
a policy where c d couldn't go to a
landfill it had to go to a c d processor
the c d processors aren't going to be
able to
recycle 100 percent of the waste
as representative mcwilliams alluded to
massachusetts has set a basic standard
to recycle 15 percent of c d basically
the idea is
anyone who's generating c d in
massachusetts
needs to
do what they can to recover at least
fifteen percent
before it goes to disposal
so even in massachusetts they're not
banning c and d disposal outright
but they are doing things to try to
encourage recycling of that material
something like that potentially could be
considered for new hampshire but an
outright ban right now is just
it's not feasible
and it's not something that under our
current infrastructure we would be able
to support in this state
while the intention here is is obviously
something that should be considered i
think the the actual language of the
bill itself
uh is not workable and we we oppose that
so
um with that i'll leave that uh that
will
i'll leave my comments there uh if you
have any questions for me happy to
take those
questions from mr norc
yes representative simpson
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
um
so do you have a sense
of
if there's a percentage that
we might
talk about in new hampshire maybe
aspirationally
um that the department would think might
be possible of how much we could
aim to recycle of the c d
thanks representative simpson for the
question that's that's a good question
so my home committee is environment and
agriculture they know some of the
struggles that we have at the department
in terms of data and
managing
some of these issues
what we did a couple years ago was we
looked at
surrounding states have done what's
known as a materials or a waste
composition study
so that what they're doing is they're
looking at how much waste is going to
landfills and basically taking samples
and trying to figure out
by you know categorizing the waste and
trying to figure out what could be
recycled
so what we did was we looked at some of
those recent waste characterization
studies from surrounding states
to kind of get an idea and
it's not always going to be apples to
apples you know state by state but
we did look at this and we looked at the
c d stream which is less understood than
the municipal solid waste stream so
there's less data
but um
based on that analysis we figure
roughly 15 of cnd right now is
realistically
recyclable which is also in line with
where massachusetts currently is and i
think massachusetts set that standard
because
they had to start somewhere and
obviously they want to build that up
over time to recycle more and more as
but a lot of it depends on what markets
are available and what what outlets are
feasibly available to recycle these
materials that's really what when
something is defined as recyclable it's
really
it comes down to where it you know where
you can
take it or where you can
um you know what you can do with it and
that's that's dependent on markets
any other questions
i guess
sort of a follow-up to that question and
that is
does the department have in place a plan
to migrate in that direction
currently we don't have a stated
plan
this is something that i think we've
talked about internally we don't
necessarily have
a policy or
part of our challenge is that our
authority under rsa 149m
is that we don't necessarily have
the ability to make rules that would
impose a ban on disposal or mandate
recycling
so our ability to work within that space
is a little bit tenuous but
we are charged with
updating a solid waste management plan
for the state
and that might be a venue where we could
explore possibilities
it's not to say that we would be able to
enact a broad policy that might need
legislation
any
any other questions
sigmund thank you for your testing thank
you
is there anyone else who'd like to
testify on house bill 1544
seeing no one we will close the hearing
on house bill 1544
i think that concludes our business for
the day
i want to thank the committee members
who hung in here all day long i
appreciate that
and
we will reconvene at nine o'clock
tomorrow morning
thank you everyone
one of the most wonderful things
right i think there's some potential
but really i mean i'm kind of
agreeing with what they have to say
first of all we don't have any
recyclables
uh yep
it's not one thing i think
it's not favoring maybe the legislation
within the last
this whole recycling industry